bonsoir fab c'est le coeur c'est tout le
monde quand ça va bien ça va femmes
c'est la grande finale grande brune
despitch estimant donc 100% américaine
avec hikaru contre toutefois cet essor
est normalement et carbo gros gros
favoris web
hikaru gros gros favoris mais mais une
compétition appelle des surprises
bah ouais il a perdu deux finales le
studio jamais deux sans trois ouais il a
perdu les deux fois ouais c'est vrai
t'as raison de le souligner deux finales
deux défaites c'est la catastrophe anapu
ricard ou les amis et wesley est ouest
et qui n'a pas encore joué en finale
c'est sa première finale de ce pitch s
puisque les neuf dernières finales en
fait c'était la fiche hikaru magnus et
donc quelque part
en l'absence de magnus a permis un autre
joueur de se hisser ouais mais car où il
tient les tient son standing gagner ces
matches en fait un ensemble
finalement c'est aronian hier soir qu'il
a mis le plus en danger mais sans
l'avoir vraiment mis en danger non plus
quoi manger très relatifs au visage
alors j'ai réussi à avoir une info par
rapport au roi eux deux un fab
ouais mais bon je me suis un petit peu
renseigné en fait c'était un pari qu'il
a eu avec ses viewer 1
en fait c'est un peu ça grop donc j'ai
envie de dire bravo hikaru au lieu de
faire comme d'autres de copier tu vois
ouais ils ont déjà bien monté son propre
truc donc quelque part j'ai envie de
dire on sent que tu vois il malgré tout
tu vas chauve 3 x 7 prend une fois en
oui mais bon il a quand même le mérite
de ne pas faire comme les autres qui
copient converser c'est quand même bien
quoi bon tu le fais trois fois mais
moins de bruit au moins il a son propre
style coiffard par là il se bat quoi
mais bon ça va être un beau match pape
parce que parce que wesley
wesley finalement c'est peut-être le
joueur qui peut lui poser le plus de
problèmes par contre j'entends un petit
peu de bruit derrière toi comme s'ils
avaient une télé allumée ou quelque
chose à part les matches dans les jambes
une porte et jardins ok donc ça va être
une grosse soirée normalement on est en
ligne
j'imagine je sais pas si quelqu'un peut
nous écrire dans le chat pour vérifier
qu'on soit qu'on soit online mais ça
doit être le cas et donc n'hésitez pas à
partager aussi parce que parce que
malheureusement fin malheureusement
malheureusement l'information n'est pas
très partagés par les médias et chez qui
un français sur ce speech s ouais je
trouve ça va finalement je trouve ça
personnellement dommage parce que ouais
tu vas fabulizés aux gens je vais mettre
un petit lien pour qu'ils puissent
partager
je disais que je trouve un petit peu
dommage que ce soit pas du tout partagé
par par les médias et chez qui un
français parce que c'est une belle
compétition quand même et je comprends
que
que quand c'est moi on ne partage pas
quoi mais enfin c'est dommage c'est
quand même les échecs quoi je suis là
non mais toi seul oui toi c'est pas toi
seul c'est possible mais n'y manque que
je suis là en fait j'ai compris que
c'était plus possible je trouve que
c'est un peu dommage parce que bon le
speech as ça reste une belle compétition
c'est un championnat du monde officieux
de beats sur internet est ok nacaso
c'est quand même une très belle affiche
toutefois un petit peu dommage la fab
ben moi on était vulgaire qui se saisit
bah ouais nan mais c'est dommage pas
accès comme vlad invs latvalade pareil
pardon j'ai compris que ça venait de moi
mais bon peu importe c'est pas ça
l'important met donc ouais si vous
pouvez parce que ok c'est une belle
compétition et là c'est la finale et
donc je vais m attends à jojo aucune
barre je sais pas ce que tu as eu une
mention une fois flatteur à kevin quoi
la mise à part je suis mon rang sur les
vidéos youtube quoi jamais quoi mais toi
seul oui là ça va assez bien quelque
part est qu est ce qu est ce que tu ne
regrette pas quelque part est ce que tu
te dis pas ce à quoi donc battu disent
ils me parlaient pas qu'est ce que c'est
pas mauvais signe tu vas est ce que tu
dis pas toi tu prends pas ça comme comme
un contenant la gueule là je me dis je
miserais grèce en fait ouais c'est ça
mais je mets sais c'est un peu ma
question qu est ce que tu te dis pas je
suis en train de faire de la merde quoi
étayer par tüv nord
non ça va ce que j'ai fait c'est pas
possible je pense mais gère le fait
d'être partagé ça t'a pas tu t'es pas tu
t'es pas poser des questions quoi non je
fais quand même attention comme un fou
bien sûr j'aimerais parler de situations
bfm c'est pas grave c'est très dangereux
quoi voilà c'est parti à l'est du parti
parti attendu qu'elle est venue car vous
allez plus loin
ok bon moi je pense au niveau pré pas
sauvagement correctement détruits non
mais là je pense que c'est plus je pense
quand arrive en finale de la compet tu
es capable même de jouer des livrets
truc tu as de l'argent en jeu il ya un
titre mais tu vends c'est un match
vraiment très sérieux l'a conçu ce soir
j'en suis sûr ne me suis rien évidemment
donc c'est une sorte de l'a3 présent
choisi paris car où le hockey est
spécial pour l'instant esso qui veut un
peu le truc avec ses 4 et des 4 retardée
michael shank est oh ouais et donc il va
sûrement infligé une structure plus
isolé voilà bon faire coiffer ses six
j'imaginerais parce que si tu faisais le
cavalier tas de prendre des clouage
madère tu te prends quand même le damas
quatre ne date boulgou faisait saxons ou
ouais mais alors est ce qui peut bouffer
en d5 en fait et comme ça sur bouffe
beauvois la longère en proposer d'abord
et c'est quoi ces histoires sûr qu'elle
a lieu cinq ces collines quel point ses
trois marques qui peut quand même faire
tes et prend des cinq là il peut
sûrement curieux prendre sinon ouais ça
prend 2,5 contre qui marche oui j'aurais
pu refaire d'un premier cinq bloqués en
france et 6 6 reprend donc à dire est
qu'il prend des cinq offrandes et les
pas grand chose à part moi j'aurais fait
ça personnellement j'étais fou troqué
garde garde plus de jouer dans la
position mais une berne aussi somptueuse
ouais alors c'est pas forcément très
dangereux non plus pour le moment mais
bon je pense à art rock moi bêtement
baroque s'exercer de coups que tu joues
aussi ta pâte en première intention mais
cavaliers france et trois en fait du
coup il veut jouer contre le duo dion
sédé epa est pas laissée aux blancs la
presse bilan il semble tout à fait s'en
débarrasser la la menace stratégique
c'est tour à ses huit cavaliers à cinq
lycées 4 tu mets la dame en dessin tu
bloques les pions intimiste hors piste
aucune arrivée
le tchad car d'une carte de nuke c'est
un format 4 to plupart la plaire au
grand public
ils menacent qu'avait lieu le 5 la fab
ya pas cavalier cinq là alors est ce qu
est le saint-amour on essaie de forcer
que les premiers froids échec pour
commander cette carrillo 5 à savoir
parfois savoir comme seller comme à sa
double et les pions f quand même et je
pense c'était un par avenant bas en
aurait eu la bonne finale tu penses
qu'ils ont tous les deux raté ou sow l'a
pas fait parce qu'il a vu un truc tu
parce qu'il a pu voir parce que j'ai
rien à part peut-être qu'il a juste pas
envie de faire et qui se dit que son cas
il va être fort et on mettra cinq c4 et
qui préfère pas les changer ça c'est une
outro oui c'est possible il fera des
cinq à six mois là mais la cave à
lieusaint que je pense faut vraiment
faire maintenant toute façon le pion
arrive ans et quatre mois qu'elle peut
aussi faire cavalier à 5,6 dame prend 17
reprises 17 et jouer pour un tour
d'essai cette eau qui fait ni féminin ok
donc dame prend 17 vraisemblablement
sinon juste gelée blanche
madame on apprend en effet trois échecs
gf100 caen 17 et un peu mieux pour les
noirs parce que tours d'essai set on a
pressé les pions mais ça peut peut-être
se tenir à table un truc fluence et
c'est sa main symbolique non c'est un
petit avantage mais je pense qu'on est
dans par expansé avec du jeu parfait ça
doit encore être nul un but d'eric et
vous propose
oui enfin bon il est quand même gentil
il est taquin mais tours d'essai cette
honte la joue quand même un ouais mais
va prendre des sièges
ouais il ya tout qui va s'échanger les
taux vont s'échanger mais je pense que
la finale de pions tu la finale de fou
pardon tu l'as dit si peu jours à cause
de cela
ok sûrement mieux le vivre amérique et
c'est ce qui fait enfin tu joues bien
mais juste si tu acceptes tenu là c'est
trop ouest ont pu voir sur toutes ces
palabres un nul ils ont regagné le match
entre way puis tu sais en bullet on voit
bien si tu arrives en bullet même à
égalité tout peut arriver en fait sur
une demi heure le bullet c'est tellement
un jeu de 2,2 strictes comme dit vaz et
des vagues site et sur l'aude là-bas que
l'hôte est dans le creux en fait en 30
minutes de bullet tu peux gagner
théoriquement suffire par tricks le run
away passer une vague quoi
si l'hôte est dans le creux de la vague
que toi tu es au sommet de la vague
était mort quoi bon aller il faut y
aller faut y croient qu'ils croient que
oui j'y crois à fond de moi je suis à
fond la bourse ouvre en fait j'adore
naka mais je veux voir un match donc j'y
crois à fond là si je ne sus tu ne peux
pas puissent plus y croire que vous en
fait c'est pas possible j'ai envie de te
sortir le hashtag je suis wesley so tu
as faim acf
messieurs je suis un niveau de croyances
qui est quand même assez élevé j'étais
sur une solution propre arme un mois
qu'il veut faire
trois des cinq clairement mais moi j'ai
envie de dire on fait fourrer fille de
foot rouaroua 8 quand même on lui laisse
faire le pion on lui laisse sur le pion
pas s'éloigner et on ramène le roi fond
nous faut dix huit stèles autres options
un ouais
peut-être qu'on n'ait pas le temps de
courir 3,8 des cinq bouffe bout froide
et set à 5-3 c6 donc on avait le temps
quand même votre sont là on va leur en
d5
ouais mais ce qu'on n'a pas voyez
remarque qu'on n'a pas vraiment perdu du
temps mais j'aurais quand même fait
plutôt roi 8 quoi mais bon
capri joue mieux que moi je vais par la
csmf a peut-être qu'ils aient peur que
le bus arrive jusqu'en à 7 et après ils
pouvaient plus l'attaqué avec le fou et
non en fait il a super bien joué
on avait beaucoup plus fort que moi pas
référencé sur supportable la magie a
joué trois fois contre son blitz valu
une amie 3-0 quoi cette pommade avec
laurent des singles monaca va attendre
tranquille ray 3d 3 c3 et va faire
simple aller-retour mais éventuellement
dans le sens large et cinquième 5ème
4ème chasser ce chou 2 3 ok il veut
gagner un temps mais je sais pas ce
qu'on va se croient des sets 3 6 6 3 et
5 ans mais quand même wente étions
maîtres le x e 5 voire 6 appartient
je pense qu'on a envie de rouler sans
extrémités en fait je pense qu'on veut
faire g5 je pense pas qu'on touche je
pense passer 5 h 5 h 4 pour le dégager 4
x 200 m en main et chance fait g5
pour commencer on fixe les pions et
après peut-être ont fait fou et sept
fous des six mais je ferai g5 un g6 bras
de toi je perds on voit pas très clair
non
ok on va voir finale intéressante il
peut y avoir des histoires de zoom
peut-être ouais après le problème c'est
que bon les blogs gamecube et vite pour
attendre ils ont foi jeu de ses nombreux
aussi écho quand on est sûr fois hk
tison ils ont un truc aussi avec fous
ces sept ouais ouais mais attend on va
voir qui est peut-être fou ou 7 est
question pourquoi ça joue star ce soir
alors que les deux miss toujours 18h 19h
palais de l'eburnie gonesse de train je
sais pas tout en fait hein tu sais des
choses que je sais ya des choses que je
ne sais pas ça faisait partie des choses
tu ne sais pas ouais non mais c'est
peut-être les joueurs un vêtement tu
sais des fois l'explication va pas plus
loin
mais je suis content de cet horaire
oui ça serait sympa c'est un bel horaire
mais qu'est ce qu'il peut y avoir b5 ici
à b to b 6 10 août
il prend aussitôt mis trois ans devant
ouvre aimante a quand même pris des
points de base et souvent paraguay ne
ferait pas tout et faire croire mais je
veux dire j'ai appris trois heures j'ai
déjà battu saut j'ai jamais battu bah
j'ai même jamais fait un demi point mais
le pingouin j'ai faim surtout gagner 3 0
du let mais en 3 0 c'est pas si énorme
l'écart bon comme vous et c'est tout non
mais avec cinq étaient vraies b5 c'était
intéressant aussi un vraiment attendant
maintenant dessin à la place de f5 la
pure prendre de simples afp 6 1
je vais prendre ce pion là je pense
c'est ça qui l'a calculé pendant si
longtemps
ok maintenant ok maintenant il doit
qu'il a dû calculer fou g3 babou
facebook et vous fait g5 les la ducat
que la finale d'options et menacera le
truc de faire le pion par seigneur ars
oi des trois bombes à clairoix celle ci
est en feu 5 milliards brassés si
ceux-ci scora ceci suppose foulée 3 oui
mais foin de francs suisses 5
s'intéresse aussi je me suis à cinq qui
on prend des quatre à detroit mais mon
option a passé qui peut être un peu
chiant peut-être un problème là soit tu
prends at il ce 5 mai race et sinon très
bien a ok il veut roi des cinq
maintenant il va rester calmes et voilà
bon faut sortir ce foot j 3 avant de
faire enfermer paris iv mais je pense
permettant b8 ouais je pense aussi mais
je ne sais pas trop encore on passe avec
les noirs je deviens qui tu peux essayer
de revenir vers eux un d'une manière un
peu bizarre j'aurais essayé de faire
faut cette fois à trois faisans blizzard
met à table juste se tient
qui est prise prisé h4 c'est quand même
intéressant bon j'imagine ce qui confère
6 3 wade 4 mais évidemment dans la tour
des g4 qui vont vraiment des cinq il ya
cinq des quatre rois c4 des transactions
en vins à wisques quand il rappe tu
comprends et je crois avoir f3 y aura ce
gang ouest paralysie du froid des
symboles maintien je peux le mettre dans
la base des finales de pionsat bah
écoute ça commence plutôt bien pour le
suspense pour cela qu' une petite
italienne on en avait pas mal hier donc
entre à rognan et à terme 3 l'aladi que
wes les sauces était le petrosyan
moderne et que un peu comme petrosyan il
pouvait un moment donné se réveiller et
décidé de gagner quoi
bah je veux dire de se réveiller en tant
que joueur en partie longue et de
partout et de et de raser les tournois
qua non je sais pas mais il disait quoi
est il de trucs intéressants qui
disaient ouais c'est que cramique lui a
dit quand ils ont fait le stream qui
nous sidéré que c'était le plus fort ou
joueurs du monde dans des finales avec
petit avantage qu'ils soient ouais parce
qu'ils aient jamais d'erreur en fait
mais jordan comprends c'est que carlson
lui l'effort pour créer davantage
ouais mais genre sauf si tu lui donnes
l'avantagent un peu comme dans la finale
convient de voir genre que c'était un
machine pour une machine après ouais je
sais pas bons sauts en fait évidemment
très fort ne fait pas d'erreur en
général mais problème de qui firent rien
quoi
dans le jeu ouais il fait pas grand
chose est dommage serment qu'il a trop
peur de perdre ou quoi et ça n'empêche
de faire des trucs parce qu'il est
évident il est un gros rush à un moment
ou quoi mais très souvent quand ses
adversaires voulaient le battre il en
fait si genre tu joue juste oh rien
faire il est contente se passerait ouais
mais c'est ce qu'ils disaient de
petrosyan il est que petro si on avait
eu un peu la même carrière vlad ok mais
il était champion du monde oui mais que
à un moment donné il a décidé de changer
et qu'il a commencé à gagner
apparemment il faisait que des nuls
tranquille et qu'à un moment donné il en
a eu marre de faire que des nuls et il
s'est mis à écraser tout le monde faire
écraser du son style c'est un terme
armée bizarre mais il s'est mis à a
dominé en fait par ea l'a jamais été et
compte faire donner le métro sont tous
d'accord mais je pense qu'il n'a jamais
tenu un mondial en fait être au cern
ouais bah y avait pas de l'eau tout ça
dépote
oui je sais donc que dur à dire en fait
mais à mon avis il y avait 1 et 2 à
l'époque il n'aurait pas eu mais il a
quand même été champion du monde à
plusieurs reprises c'est à dire qu'il
assortit bobigny enfin et il a défendu
une fois qu'on ne sait pas ce qui
l'attend perdre ce parce qu'ils
apprendront ce 9 mai mais il a déjà
gagné plusieurs fois le titre et c'est
pas rien après il était sûrement
beaucoup plus motivés quand c'est un
match de championnat du monde comme
c'étaient les petits tournois
finalement qui retient les vainqueurs
des tournois
non mais ouverture d un et sur des
méthodes qu'il ferait son nom mais
c'était marrant parce qu'il disait ça et
un autre qui est vrai c'est que la fin
il a compris et fait un choix il a par
là s'est longtemps de socom ses matchs
contre houdoud à mélisey qui s'était mis
à comprendre toute la puissance de saut
à saint louis lors du tournoi en août en
fait tu n'aimes wec avant il avait
jamais compris mais qu'en fait depuis ce
tournoi est trouvé très très fort en
fait il ne fait pas très spécial à san
ou non mais il n'a rien fait de spécial
mais juste il a contré par une
révélation je revois les parties se
mais c'est trop long a déclaré tous
parlent de saut et je peux aller nous là
tu as commencé à dire alors que moi je
trouve très insignifiant pas mais même
alors maman me voir ils vers 2018
en plus je vous renvoie si la phase où
il avait quatre points sur neuf
mais bon il ya compris quoi tiennent au
conte probants en voiture enfin bon il
ya caruana leeuwen et karakar scène qui
ont fait cinq et demi mammadyarov 5
il est choqué nos nouvelles quatre et
demi by mais bon ce aux quatre là ouais
mais tu sais pas peut-être quand il
analyse et des trucs ou juste parce
qu'il a discuté avec on n'en sait rien
quoi mais tout d'un coup et genre de
révélations il faudra que le hockey je
leur des parties peut-être qu'il a fait
un gros truc il a fait des grosses
défenses gens sains ou qu'il a raté des
gagnants bien créer le jeu auquel vous
qui durera du génie m'a pas marqué à ses
actes c'est le fameux temps il ya peu de
départager mr oui et puis après il est
jeune encore 1 par rapport à non mais je
suis pas la critique et s'annonce donc
comme je dis il manque deux sûrement une
ambition parfois dans le jeu de dénoncer
clairement petrossian des temps modernes
ça c'est vrai que c'est une bonne
comparaison et et voilà et beaucoup et
petrossian je pense qu'ils se bouger
beaucoup plus tourné match-là du monde
surtout aux tourments il s'en fout on
fait ça mais tu as quoi mais bon
petrossian il a été longtemps la fin
déjà en 53 il faisait quand on est
candidat le fameux g duré que 53 mais
pas de bretagne de quoi et son premier
titre de champion je pense à 63 quand il
sort d'unique donc je dois déjà dix ans
ce niveau là avant et de téléphone qui
fait un bruit je sais pas où je n'y suis
pas mais ils dominaient encore 1,7 par
tissot clairement arrive le meutre en
vibreur pour ne plus y ait des dix
visites mais là en fait il a mis
carrément en pls hikaru
la côte il ya 2 0 ça fera faire bouger
de match parce qu au moins ça va aider à
ce que le carreau gère trop après
l'incroyable ainsi s'ils se gagne ouais
ouais disons moi j'y crois pas du tout
de buzz écoute
non mais hier on n'y croyait pas non
plus ni l'un ni l'autre non mais alors
qu'edf 3 bon je pense à réchauffer farc
et les fils des 5 ou des saintes d'abord
chez poc me veut et v3 ok en tout cas on
repart donc ces petites variantes il
décide de push juin va débattre ricky le
pas de deux grosses prépa en face mais
juste faire jouer mais pas de chance
mais sur un souk honnêtement la maison
en plus dans la théorie il est souvent
très bien préparés bon je vais me
prendre dans ces cinq pays doit
connaître
hop tu as ont presté 5 certes on vous
abîmer les pions après fonds propres si
je prends mon général je pense pas que
ce soit très grave
le nord c'est hyper intéressant de
regarder les stream de draka d'ailleurs
parce que quand il joue je vois en fait
ils regardent pas les mêmes coûts que
nous en premier je sens qu'il regarde
les choses différentes et non seulement
ils calculent plus vite non plus j'ai
l'impression qu'il un meilleur feeling
sur certains trucs c'est assez marrant
parce qu'en matière stream et après donc
sûrement pas étonnant c'était bizarre en
fait genre d être sûrs en moi j'aurais
eu peur jour les calculs du nom là il
n'y a plus rien tu vas enfin il se
faisait attaquer le roi mais il a tout
de suite vu que en fait si mais moi
depuis calcul puis qui sait plus vite il
n'y voit enfin c'est un peu comme si tu
avais la pression avec un mec à 15 cents
mais les kiwis mais ça ça peut pas
marcher ouais mais c'est ça mais c'est
incroyable mais genre à tempo tu vois
genre déjà il calcule plus vite et c'est
meilleur feeling dois faire ça peut
marcher
souvent des gens beaucoup de portes
oui mais bon à part ça montre la
différence de niveau est une chose dont
dans l'étagé au-dessus quoi c'est juste
hallucinant comme tata 6b 5 mai sur a6
il va faire un carrosse ne peux pas me
rabaisser d'affaires à 4 non puisque les
a dits voit quand même son destin
pas tout de suite le truc c'est que le
fou il n'a pas trop de cases le fou en
c4 du coup si tu fais b5 c'est cool man
[Musique]
est sur b4 nature les cavaliers à 4 les
trucs comme ça
position et peut-être organes en fait
sur un viol les fous des quatre essais 4
sont pas très bien placé je pense en
réalité non ça veut penser aux trucs de
même accepté ces finales la possible
mais je pense qu'elle va lire à 4 ou
highway
après il y avait cinq mais je pense
qu'il faut des cinq dessus web et 5 fu
des cinq peut-être fou 17 à ce moment là
wayne bush sur ses sept déjà des
concessions ouais
après peut-être aussi mme même et
cavaliers à 4,4 en fait pourquoi pas
donc et même une baie 5.25 d'ailleurs
s'en sont pas au dessous des 5
mais oui non et qu'il y ait au 4 10 à 4
je vais agir d re 4 par c'est un coup
vraiment très important d'être k4 ces
mines effectivement les camps sont en
tout cas il vend à 4 bon au moins ça
mérite d'éviter ce que des blondes
pouces 1/4 même et faire comme les sacs
à pain où il va juste tombé si bas je
pense c'est une chance le b 5 c'est ce
que tu veux faire de base
basé sur un ce que ce truc c'est que
prisent prises et aurait même à cinq qui
arrivait au caire a tu peux jouer
maintenant tu faire aussi qu'il db6
bizarrement un code qui avait d'abord
régalé des systèmes pas trop ce qu est
ce qu a valu aux cinq lycées 6 nord
n'ont peut-être fou 17 mai fera tour
c'est cette renom proches trop bouger le
flou absolu à veiller à b6 ok ok il veut
attendre pays ces trois faits refouler
700 kg et or ce soft met donc fait pour
l'instant il ya fou décision peut-être
caïds et 2 mais sur quoi il veut faire
flamber sept fous des cinq et il pourra
reprendre du cavalier mais tu vois moi
je suis un cavalier prend fou prend
peut-être cavalli ces quatre jours à
regret le pion et je serais fou 17 pour
jeu l'activité a et pro b 6
bon repas de programmes non moi je sais
pas je voulais une tour 17 mois mais bon
petit peu de faire du fou c'est cette
4ème en qualifs et capte sur sa tombe
mais je pense qu est peut-être qu'il
sait 4 quand même je sais pas ouais mais
je suis peu ce fait un super fan de
final four nations trucks ça marche à
notre niveau de merde mais pas le pas
aux leurres quoi bon ok il des deux
sûrement têtu faire peut faire f 4 au 6
mai mon mari qu'elle sait trop mauvais
non at t a troqué les prends d'apprendre
quoi prendre le chou de la tour ok ta
tête tourbe et 7 passes que sur fou
prend fou prend garde à toi qui as un
prises qui est mon tour des huit agences
est toujours égale juste ça demande plus
de précisions pour les noirs or mme
savard un peu embêté plus que prévu car
où notre position je pense vraiment rien
en fait tout près faut faut souligner
que que sow il réussit bien pour le
moment autant autant à travers mais je
serai vite en fait c'est bien il fait
exactement ça y est je vais vite et bien
et l'a peut-être cavaliers detroit aussi
ceux-là qui traînent jean reprises 5
malin est un pion g2 qui restera emprise
de l'autre côté je pense qu'il ya des
trois c'est une vraie menace
pakaya détroit c'est une menace si c'est
sûr qu'il va voir hikaru ça c'est pas
trop caché non mais les messins qui est
pas d soit pas si grave en fait je fais
3 tu prends des quatre cheveux quatre
fers grands noms mais voilà c'est pas si
mal points noirs se serait bien passé et
tout à perdre de chou enfin justo pas
trop grave non plus mais après tu va
refaire foule s'est tue à repartir mais
je lui qui est des fous de bassan ce
genre touchant suprend pas en d4 direct
après 5h 3 j'imagine que tu fais un truc
avant tu vas commencer par fouet cette
quelque chose ça 3 intéressant un
système de eye tracking le stream qui
ont sécoué crainte ni ouais c'est truc à
la mode sur youtube qui ont plein de
vidéos comme ça où tu regardes où tu
vois où vous regarde les yeux je sais
pas à quel point c'est vraiment
scientifique sont rigueur je pars à quel
point il sait vraiment où tes yeux
regardent plus ou moins sentir ta zone
ouais mais bon j'ai ressenti surtout
pour faire le boss tu vois ce que je
veux dire surtout vu les photos qui
montrent tu comprends tu comprends ou
sarsgaard imagine bien ce que ça regarde
c'est pour ça que je lis ces lignes
excuse pour montrer d'autres choses quoi
bien ce que je pensais pas faire un buzz
d'enfer buzz et je passe un truc comme
fou c'est si c'est jouable mais c'est un
peu peyrieu bongo faisait 10 si ça
marche vraiment le maître reiki
oui peut-être en finlande en inde en
truck scientifique ou quoi oui mais à
quel point ça marche sur les trucs
qu'ils utilisent sur leur pc personnel
tu vois je suis fan je sais pas
mais j'ai 5 c'est bizarre j'ai pas du
tout aimé
[Musique]
hu
faire quoi truc c'est qu'il y avait 6
qui a aidé cinq situations sa part est
allé parce qu'il va te faire e 4 bref
peut-être faire kébé 6 quand même et
peut être viser la case 17 au pire mars
exactement ce qu'il fait mais qu'elle
est toujours pas si ce sera quelque
chose a relaté moins bien en plus t'as
le mauvais fou par rapport à la
structure depuis un genre si tu avais
une flambée 8 mai montrait première
éruption à 6 en fait on fout il est
complètement engluée quoi elle va
trembler cinq bus devrait y tenir
[Musique]
non mais là faut qu'ils tiennent ce
parti c'est un bon indicateur pour la
suite du match
en tout cas ce qui est bien tu vois
c'est que bon on arrive là dans le money
time de la partie on est à 40 secondes
contre 43 lui il le tient au dos c'est
déjà de façon la condition sinequanone
da sinéquanone pardon à toute surprise
de fab s'il tient pas temporellement il
tiendra pas à quoi on est obligé de
tenir en termes de temps et bon après la
position mais ok pour ainsi se bat bien
et il faut pas prendre b4 cafo à 3,6 à
l'échec peut être soit 3 que l'échec et
urmatt à tour en dessins qui désireront
17 hockey borgia français sera si je
sais nul m contre les blancs d'autres se
résoudre à ça parce que cali aussi son
prochain coup de théâtre est atteint il
veut prendre fcf suroît machin il veut
faire tourner ses 6 mai tandis qu'ils
avaient trois ok qu'il est et ça peut
être qu'il faut aussi faire cavalier
aussi sur l'aspect retour prend 1,5 mais
la tour en 1 4 les psys sont copiés pas
de match quand j'ai eu trois sets et
pourquoi les noirs c'est pas mieux ici
même jusqu'aux quais tour j'aurais mis
la tour 1 4 direct
mais bon tant b5 et b6 belge a pas pesé
- gilles dionne qui serpente bas le fou
quoi
oui normalement ça se tient
et c'est second chrono 24 sa f 5 500
jours à deux coups qui me font peur
bombay 2 500 ans qu'elle est moins bien
on doit tenter un bon faut pas d'accent
quoi cette tour h6 je sais pas parler
mais il est malin pour la terrible
impression aussi ce re5 il va se faire
mater au kkl c4 kavanagh ya pas mal
parce que y'a royal oak si ce n'était
pas mal à un moment donné un bon
classement n'était pas ma paie 2 2 je
pense qu'au final de se tenir parce
qu'il aurait vraiment dû mettre le
cavalier russie sur le 17 comme ça
n'aurait pas été réseau thé mais
pourquoi toutes les pris de mauvaises
décisions mais bon peu près du perron 5
aussi un frein mais sûrement pour à
quatre en un temps c'était mieux que
furent cet échec inutile là bas il a
tout mon père m'en vais gagner 3 c3 quoi
provoquer de retourner dans l'italienne
inoki carouge chaque jour confrontés les
voisins chrétiens bien quoi il est en
forme et ça a été intéressant d'ailleurs
son match à londres contre en
demi-finale contre fabiano s'agirait en
fait parce que dis toi bien que s'y perd
une des deux parties en longues
fabien de numéro un mondial au mondial
d'ailleurs il on m'a offert un
abonnement à la chaîne d'hikaru hier
établie quant aux wem a tant souffert
lundi car ouest je fais des petits
carreaux dans le chat je serai heureux
moi je le vois il ya des tas de big
house et 64 a failli lui c'est brian
d'hikaru quoi je suis là quoi j'avais
fait deux parts and sun nah dans la
bouche avec ce qu'il est il a une
sucette il adopte le suricate adopter
des gages baroud scène il a réussi à
l'adopter mais c'est quoi la casquette
la cgn hikaru à quoi je fasse sa
casquette c'est très heureux tu vois 114
est très heureux aussi
je sais pas quel genre venons enfin les
secteurs ou des métiers tout le monde
est partout que c'est génial à son récit
qu en scène était adoptée par paris
carine à midi 0 dégage
il aurait pu être un petit une petite
you will find aussi dire oui fans
surtout bonne chance à fond climatique
mans je n'ai pas écrit maman j'ai vu
tomber une merde c'est pas écrit pas de
chance non mais là les adhérentes a
décrit non bah oui mais elle avait
refusé
oui pigeon c'est son scanner avec doodle
on a déjà la place est prise par wim on
aurait pu leur nom mais dans les joueurs
intéressants qui cherchent des équipes
ces gens qui managent yannick qui
cherche une équipe
ben nous on est foule mais les banques
helléniques
photo dp je peux marseille non ah bon il
faut le savoir mais il cherche une
équipe dont on voit les cds manager des
équipes qui traîne
l'étrangère tu vas peut-être supa
américaine ou quoi sur ce stream en
français vin il est dans la liste des
joueurs qui cherchent une équipe et je
pense à mes recrues un ouais mais dès
que tu es plus locale soit bien moins
intéressant ouais mais bon enfin dans
une équipe qui est foule locale
tu vois c'est mais qui mettait toujours
trop tard pour un étranger
à 2007 doazit bas c'est comme si nous on
avait pas à duda et que les pneus ok tu
vas te fasse honte a pas d'étranger et
yannick quand même il est 26 14 au 1er
septembre
c'est une belle recrue c'est clairement
une gamme d'antennes relais après je
veux dire ce que prendre des we found
peut prendre je suis pas sûr que des
gens fut passeur chauffeur ou ifa d'un
yannick a franchement non non moi je te
donne un exemple tu vois que tu veux
programme prendre un étranger mathaf
irun a aussi fait unique mais voilà même
toi tu dis juste que ça parce que je les
ai vus dans la lys et que c'est une
recrue intéressante et qui les français
donc voilà je donne un petit coup de
pouce à yannick e66 voilà si quelqu'un
cherche un joueur je sais pas a très
probablement non mais enfin tu as julan
je lance une bouteille à la mer soyez un
joueur français intéressant sur la liste
et il ya un autre joueur intéressant
mais qui est très gourmand
financièrement c'est s'élèveront les
vents qui demande 700 par match c'est un
peu cher après les objectifs des
sponsors ou quoi ils peuvent se
permettre nous on a peut être une sorte
si je m'en mets de l'argent c'est toi et
moi notre poche
balla et là dedans c'est quand même
c'est autre chose
l'adidas et moi mais la bonne recrue
après un push le chat devos l'eso est
jolie ouais il est sympa son choix non
mais les bonnes aussi même une belle
forcément un bon joueur non mais bien
sûr web
justement on peut pas lâcher 700 par
match je pourrai ainsi j'ai vraiment
envie mais à quoi ça sert à quoi sert la
pression on fait péter tout l'équipe i
peut-être on peut on croire prendre un
joueur comme ça tu le dis by finance
l'équipe
ouais après problème c'est que tu dois
le faire jouer deux matchs en fait si je
pouvais le faire jouer qu'une fois en
playoffs tout en quarts de finale pour
te qualifier tu as dû miser tout sur un
match et tu dis ok je recrute mais le
problème c'est que tu es obligé de faire
jouer deux matches il est obligé de
jouer à rage en saison régulière
ouais et ses 1400 euros ouais c'est un
petit peu cher ouais c'est un petit peu
cher mais bon enfin genre il peut y
avoir une équipe qui le recrutent pas ce
que c'est
tu peux tu peux dire qu'il fait jouer
deux matchs à 1 tu y mascaret lieu trois
lacs à main pour un ferment à tour
peut-être pas bon être bouger le roi m 4
nages des x 4 de l'élu contre je la
presse et le coup c'est du coup
thématiques en 2005 j
et karoui calcul il a fait un petit
machin qui veulent radicaliser quatre
parties russe et clément lefert aussi un
gros chat feu attaque le cavaly attaque
le fou 17 donc il faut il te faut un
truc pour cent donc ouais après ce fait
d'un match 5e s'arrêtera tout prendre ça
il faut faire piéger cas d'échec et
qu'il prend machin qui allaient prendre
un avion il ya peut-être tout reprend 17
qui est prend 17 et tourcoing 8 part
dans les caves agnès prise tout reprend
il s'en fout ok mais là il va quand même
se prendre 5 dans de bonnes conditions
il a pas de super bien mais avant il
veut tarmac et keyyo 4 des machines bon
sens n'est donnée pour un bon ok mais tu
veux pas tout prendre on dessin skc 2
qui traîne à la fin tu veux faire quoi
je t'entends pas du tout sa coupe j sur
cahier des cinq il ya tous ces deux
risques jiwei à ces deux qui traîne
tu peux pas prendre et surtout tu peux à
moitié bien et sur cavaillon 3 c'est
quoi l'idée profond passé tour des
quatre hockey en tout cas il a le temps
et réfléchie est vraiment toi
ouais il a le temps mais faudrait pas
non plus se tromper est cependant très
peu ça qu'est la dame et encaisser les
pièces et machin mais bon tu peux faire
genre tout reprend des 5 fu prend des
cinq cavaliers trois temps des cadres
des cadres des quatre mais bon tout cas
pas même sûr qu'elle ait procès trop de
faire ton pensée cadre d'un prêt à
reprendre ses droits ce moment-là et
internes
donc ils échangent par ce biais la tour
dans ce cas trith assez chiante mais
comment ces shows avoir des coups comme
ça enfin faire avoir et un calcul et en
blitz est hyper dur
[Musique]
webb à ce niveau d'exigence pour des
missions speechless faut répondre à un
défi aux défis naka quoi il est très
tranquille et français trois services de
qualité mais il va revenir vers 4 faire
une fourchette
c'est pas son tour 4 mais ok ça va
encore stand des quatre cavaliers ou 4
et or 18es chaque fois tour des huit
échecs
pourquoi tant d 8 échecs opère deux
chacun fasse et pas sur un échec une
tour en huit là quand même
mais moi je délire je te perds de quoi
alors je te perds complètement en fait
c'est pour ça j'en viens plein de fois
jean pas parce que tu ta je te boss
bizarres et plein de fois j'entends pas
et c'est pour ça à la fois que je te
demande de répéter les coupables et non
mais là pour le coup j'ai dit une
connerie
ouais mais ça avait quand même respect
donc en fait je me disais que c'était
une variante et que et qui me manquait
quelque chose ok mais ça c'est juste ça
va il arrivait à tenir mais ok c'est nul
facile bref à tout le monde arrive à
tenir finalement passé n'a qu'à quitter
plus sur la défensive mais c'était une
partie très complexe auquel arrive
records sont des trains qu'il y aurait
peut être là l'ouverture de la partie
d'avant hier foot cavaliers ans et 5e
tribeca pas tout ça mais pour le coup je
demande toujours pourquoi pas mais s'ils
sont atteints
en vraie assise v5 tout à l'heure ils
n'étaient pas assis malin non non ça là
y'a juste c'est plus conservatif coib si
ce n'est de prendre des a4 était machin
non je sais pas enfin mais ça a sûrement
ses défauts aussi quoi juste je sais pas
exactement qu'un région ces deux sont
jouables
clairement je sais pas je veux depuis
longtemps c'est cela je n'avais pas joué
avec b6 perso mais après c'est jouable
aussi juste en général je préfère matt
l'option b 5 mais c'est plus une
question de goût que de nike 2 peut-être
que sow il aime bien jouer plus avec le
plan b 5 aussi je sais pas après à ce
niveau là ils ont ils ont moins de goût
que nous quand même dans le sens où ils
ont mangé tout est précis et mais bon on
va marquer alors niveau vaut mieux jouer
des positions que tu sens bien que bas
on a l'exemple des landes avec les
carlsbad ou même plus proche de nous les
départage avec caruana qui sentait
vraiment pas la position nageurs dans la
chaîne chimique au fouet mais ok autant
à travers des partages l' hyper mal joué
mais je peux comprendre la première
moins que ce qui est horrible on la met
sous pression ils jouent mal cette
position c'est tout enfin ce qu'elle
peut d'ailleurs des 6èmes la deuxième il
prend juste beaucoup de choix dodo
risques et c'est est inadaptée mais mais
il est mené 1-0 et bon ok je peux
comprendre en fait tu tentes on voit
tout jeune maire principal c5 c6 et son
ca marche pas tu perds tu sais pas mais
moi je sais pas blaguer avec ses 5 c'est
ça montrer que tu comprends rien mais
bon j'en sais rien après bach mais
effectivement c'est suspicieux quoi
enfin tu te dis c'est pas censé trop
marché ok moi si ça marche tout gagné
marche pas tu perds pas c'est juste
y a pas de retour en arrière j'ai pas
d'opinion mais justifie que ça
n'appartient pas à cette position
disons leur centre on a vu ça a été un
problème très vite et ne jamais vouloir
rocqué bizarre quand même
mais non c'est après un parti j'ai
vraiment pas compris son gucci a et b 5
pour moi c'est ça montre juste pas les
deux savons juste que c'est pas son spa
son type de position c'est tout non mais
qui est le 59e mais tu le vois cliquez
ici talca et 17 cloud et qu'il troquait
proceed faut qu'on sait qu'à tout de
suite ou bouche pas comment tu rentres
la demande tu fais juste qu'ils aient
bessette est évident que les 6,5 est
accueilli le merlan bessette et aux
quêtes et passifs mais attachante on
peut être en plus tu en verras que tu as
la paire non mais tu parles de cette
fois pas si je pensais que tu parlais de
la partie 12 premières parties rentrer
dans ces genres de la tchétchénie kof
ah non parti 12e n'est pas mais c'est
peut-être une forme
c'était une faute de calcul aussi le
truc de cali p 5 bah je comprends pas
j'avais fait quelques coups paca est 5e
le voc
non mais peut-être qu'il a juste oublié
que vous pensez 4 c'était possible avec
l'arrêt des sujets sains que les souks
et des caps qu'il prenait ben oui c'est
ça a réagi pour prendre ce match mais
bon 5 solide il a peut-être payé la tête
du lavoir en tout ils sacrifient une
pièce compte trois pions aussi est en
fait juste fou croire ces quatre fois ci
si les coups simples ça c'est où tu
cherches même pas le mec qu'a pas du
chiqué cherche pas tard fou g5 il prend
juste on pions et de prendre aussi 30 ou
pas mais sous pression elle était
toujours des erreurs d'après ici
apprécie revient 28 pour le coup il a
fallu tenir cette finale avec l'option
de moins mais juste j'ai un trou
incroyable dire que cavalier vite qui
est des six fautes
déjà parce que tour cédé 1 mais au moins
fait qu'elle ait beissat à ce moment là
non mais essaie de te rappeler des
tournois où tu as joué des parties à
fort enjeu en rapide car dd partage bas
ok mais j'étais très jeune même est ce
que tu te rappelles jeu la pression je
vais gagner oui non peut-être à gagner
mais je repars là que tu te rappelles la
pression peut-être que ça mais non mais
bien sûr mais tu joue moins bien mais
d'accord c'est la vie mais jarre federer
jocko compte il ya deux balles de match
federer
ou extérieur je vous renvoie la balle
sur la ligne l'adaptation aux ciseaux ni
fils de grand chelem et il tape la ligne
oui mais il a vite c'est l'habitude non
médecin des rockets zidane faire un
penalty lima ils mettent de la pression
aux côtés même et c'est pas pareil c'est
coupe du monde de foot
non mais c'est pas pareil parce que
c'est c'est non mais sentant bien la
pression ça existe on est les premiers à
en souffrir et tout le monde dont sa
mère s'il était un sport qui fait que tu
te considères comme tels que tu sens un
très grand champion mais arrête tu joues
pour s'être sur la barrière en fait m et
47 cents soit 4 cents
c'est le bon exemple battre est bien bon
mais je veux dire à ces pressions qui je
pense je peux entendre pas entendre la
pression comme argument à ce niveau là
amincie ici ici ici forcément ainsi bien
sûr que si bien sûr mais si c'est ça
c'est une chose mais bien sûr que si la
pression ça joue barrière c'est comme si
tu as vote en france tu sais plus faire
de vélo non plus dans une montagne non
mais c'est différent
ok c'est pareil dans tous quoi mais
s'est dit non c'est différent ce que les
échecs c'est pas physique au caire les
mecs prennent quand même des bonnes
décisions la peur du temps en temps
votre sa fille un million d'euros jamais
on ne peut guère c'est discutable car
c'est ma mère je ne sais plus on a plus
d'exemples puisés physique on peut
encore laisser poker bleus va parler
c'est juste pas normal de craquer sous
la pression
c'est facile à dire mais c'est hyper du
regard les poteaux gold voilà le golf ce
sera un bon exemple mais par exemple à
tiger woods dans les derniers trous il
va tout échange et marc antoine finale
gagnante il va la gagner mais on arrive
à gagner il va tout échange en d3 et
doit gagner mais regarde tiger woods par
exemple il est connu pour être hyper
fort pour péter dans les
mais c'est me wade pour ça qu'il est
champion mais ta plainte à taraz mais
qui peut être numéro 4 mondial et ça
peut être son point faible parce que
c'est très très très compliqué non mais
je suis d'accord mais c'est
combien c'est hyper compliqué de jouer
son meilleur niveau et surtout que les
échecs c'est plus dur que les autres
c'est plus dur que les autres parce que
tu peut pas dégager fissa fait il
devrait prendre des pauses non à celle
de repos skulls socoa by orange s est ce
que dans leur s le foot ou quoi tu des
foules en fait là en fait l'objet
d'intérioriser tout ça c'est intériorise
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à gérer
mais de façon à revenir toujours notre
même des blogs et des partis trop longue
et que de tenir cette heure chaque jour
comme ça en fait pas bon et qu' il y
aurait peut-être des partis plutôt
rapide serait moins de tension nerveuse
au final je comprends ce que voulait
dire que c'est pas une excuse ne sera
pas champion mais ça je comprends bien
mais le truc c'est que des gens qui sont
capables de tenir la pression si tu
regardes le livre de tendler que j'avais
lu sur le poker en fait naturellement ta
que 10 % des gens qui sont capables de
se dépasser sous pression naturellement
certains 90% des gens quand tu l'aimés
sous pression ils vivent moins bien
comme ça c'est déjà le truc naturel si
si t'as rien fait si t'as pas fait de
mental ou quoi tu as une personne sur
dix donc là c'est le cas de carlson
clairement qui va être plus fort sous
pression est un 9 sur 10 qui vont perdre
leurs moyens et en fait sur ces aides
restent des mecs qui sauf cool fin qui
ne sont pas meilleurs comme un bon ouais
peut-être mais en tout cas on n'a que un
sur dix qui réussit à faisait passer
sous pression déjà sauvé là je m'arrête
n'ont même pas de jeu ne bat se
surpasser largement de faire cailler
bessat tout qui est bessin c'est dur
quoi mais il est pas capable de le faire
enfin c'est tout enfin monsieur dans ce
match comme ça c'est comme ça mais là
mais bon oui non mais je vous envoie des
supers champions il n'a pas des
milliards mais non il n'a pas beaucoup
au foot un chien des médecins leur match
oui et non c'est un sport collectif
aussi le foot dure à comparer n'est pas
seule est dure à comparer avec les
échecs dans le tennis tu as pris un bon
exemple clairement mais bon qui sont
capables de se dépasser
quand c'est chaud il y en a pas
énormément je voulais pas tellement de
craquer ans qu'il fait
derek crabb dès que tu sors tu dis que
tu sort du top 10 mondial c'est comme tu
vas sur les forums de paris c'est jack
lang quoi ça plein de mecs titre choc à
faire à bloc mais dans les meilleures
voies ils sont vraiment bon arbre je
pense qu aux échecs on devrait avoir des
coach mental des trucs comme ça
qui sait pas trop qui me sonia trilogie
way marques comme blizzard quoi c'est
s'il ya bien un truc mental c'était ça
et de juste d'arriver être à 100% c'est
déjà beaucoup mais bon c'est aussi le
format parce que tu vois là sur les
speech est cependant flatter en finale
tu sens pas qu'il y en a un des deux qui
qui en difficulté s'est passé comme si
au tennis pour prendre l'exemple du
tennis us face comme si le match se
jouait sur un point et qu'en fait un
point on pouvait se renvoyer la balle 70
fois d'affilée tu vois ce serait facile
comparé comme ça parce que non mais
regardez pas le match de légende
wimbledon 2008 federer nadal
ok vous fédé ils gagnent nos terroirs du
troisième ligne de 7,01 gagne troisième
sady guèye notamment de 4e set il ya des
balles de match à sauver
il ya un moment où nadal lui tape son
point faible le revers et monte à la
volée bon ok vous passing long de ligne
il va quand même perdre le match au
cinquième set machine personnelle mais
hier le point où il ya eu la balle de
match il peut la tramblais mettre des
cloches nuit du court j'ai fait le job
qu'il faut faire et voilà c'est tout
ouais mais ces différences et c'est un
système de scoring différence et c'est
plus facile quand tu es chaud aussi et
que tu as déjà de cette derrière toi que
tu as joué beaucoup de pointe est plus
en confiance c'est plus chaud pain là
c'est hyper dur le truc de scoring quoi
tarifs ses premières parties c'est déjà
un truc décisif c'est hyper dur tu vois
des fois les mecs de trois semaines que
tu joues ouais mais tu arrives tu
t'assieds devant ta table tu vois plein
de fois le maquis rendant sa finale
et comment se fabrique à 0,40 et puis le
match continue et puis ça joue mais les
positif à leur demande mais les premiers
jeux il ya plein de fois même en finale
du grand chelem où c'est n'importe quoi
les deux trois premiers jeux les mecs
ont besoin de se régler de rentrer dans
max arrive plein de fois aux échecs on
demande aux mecs de performer tout de
suite là maintenant c'est a même pas le
temps de rentrer dedans et c'est tout de
suite décisive s'est tout de suite dans
le tie break dance et l'hyper du riz
long grain 9 novembre le match on le
voit par jour trois semaines de matchs
si c'était si facile il ferait sais
c'est que c'est hyper dur c'est
forcément hyper dur non mais je pense
que ni aussi éprouvant pour les nerfs il
ya rien à dire
gérard les halles et rue mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que hockey notre
histoire d'avec les parties lentes ça va
pas c'est aussi vrai quoi est ce que là
aujourd'hui je vois les mecs sont du
blitz qui sont là ça va ils sont
tranquilles ouais ils font leur match
est sûre c'est sûr mais c'est plus
facile je pense c'est plus facile de tu
vois quand le truc est moins responsable
que tu rentres que tu as le temps de te
mettre en confiance et tout c'est tout
de suite plus simple quoi le truc de but
en blanc tu vois un tie break c'est
chaud coiffe info c'est vrai c'est
vraiment magique et aujourd'hui on fait
si tu commences n'est pas chaud tiéné
3,02 j'étais très mal pour le final
cause mais c'est différent ça ça donne
moins cette impression mais bien ramé
mais la finale chevet du monde les
départagera quatre parties pain quand
même une super la première matin encore
3 pour revenir largué même et tu sens
breaké au début du match
au tennis avoir été breaké c'est pas
breton pure affaire c'est mon père qui
assaillent tu accueilles procès qui
avait fait sa renommée sur blu-ray fuite
ike avait lieu salle catoire prend un
sens puisque qu'elle protège du coup je
veux d'autres il a été rossé 5-1 dans le
projet sonne bien
damas de ouais pourquoi quoi américaine
g3 emprise d'un f3 mieux quand même bon
quoique il ya aussi ceci peut-être damas
deux d'un projet 3 ou 6 bon départ pour
sa cinquième à six épreuves cinq encore
et peut-être sur dame pranger 3 tu peux
commencer par tourcoing f5 améliorer
dame b 3
il y aura aussi après terme et 3,6 non
non non maintenant est ce qui sera aussi
bien sur wii du coup il y aura aussi ce
oui clairement mais aussi ce qu'est ce
qu'il a prévu
et s'il va faire genre tours 7 si on
prend et dames 3 mais mon sap à l'aréna
fou ans mais tu t'es changer d'un 45 tu
prends 17 d'attac des quatre quand même
au passage des foulées de saint génis
ouais mais c'est notre à peu près fait
est bien en place
je vous prends plein sinon raconte speed
and bon mais là c'est bien pour les
blancs clairement le voir les échecs aux
jo on sent la japan autres mais
hollywood puisque les jeux vidéo y vont
j'étais au courant ils vont jouer au
l'aï dit ce porte
non je crois qu'ils veulent pas qui veut
pas les jo bats ou les histoires drôles
les deux je pense pas les histoires
c'est clair qu'ils veulent pas trop
basse mais l'ajout quoi aller courir qua
non les esport ils veulent pas se mêler
ils veulent pas voir deux fédérations en
fait assez mal pourrait en fait les
problèmes
ouais en fait c'est exactement ça c'est
que en fait ils ont enfin un souci c'est
que ta ta ta ta ta d'état une fédération
du sport je sais pas si elle est créée
où elle veut ce crime et qui veut
remettre et c'est écrire une ligne et eu
à les mettre tous les mettre ensemble en
fait et enfin créer une fédération du
sport tas et avoir tous les jeux
ensemble mais en fait les jeux ils
pensaient beaucoup mieux de rester en
privé parce que c'est beaucoup plus
efficace et ça évite un tas de problèmes
comme on le voit dans beaucoup de sports
d'ailleurs les fédérations c'est souvent
des preuves de corruption
atik et sa part très mal très vite en
tête après un essai les gens ne sont
plus là pour pour développer le jeu mais
mais développer autre chose éviter ça
donc ça m'étonnerait que après c'est
possible que cette fédération là elle
pousse pour pour à l'audio et je pense
qu'elle est cependant différent j'ai
omis les échecs bon truc un pion de plus
mais plus pour longtemps
bref quelques cavaliers eu quatre là
quand même l'hémorragie pro f 5 kg 3 et
d'un pro b 2-1 prend les docks et pour
ne prendre quatre ça ouais c'est pour ça
qu'il voulait faire qualifier trois
électeurs d'avoir un f5 et g3 qu'on peut
jouer à pas grand chose
je suis pas y en a tellement de partout
j'ai pas l'impression qu'on puisse faire
quelque chose sur le roi noir parce
qu'il est bien défendu quand même bon il
va pour ça il va pour sa part 2,3 ok je
pas au poker on savait pas mais
peut-être qu'il y avait à tour ff iii
non mesdames n'est peut-être ça c'est
plus fort aussi bêtement
non ma tête j'avais un troupeau de
gagner aussi mais ça si c'est plus fin
cela peut mal chronos dames j'ai trois
échecs en tout cas suivi de l'amf rangée
de maths donc un truc à défendre en est
d'amener ça va peut-être fou et 5e tour
pranger de en force et tours d2 le
retour ça pas mal noces se passe tout
juste fou tout ça bien sûr fait actifs y
ait quoi cela est sûr
qui fausse un accès plus ou moins forcé
non parce qu'on pense que faire d'autre
de cette façon ok mais touré ferait pas
juste dame eu deux dames g5
nous devons donc bien je vois pas en
fait juste comment tu défends le match
qu'ils pensent qu'aux si la dame prend
enfin aussi annoncé un projet phare n'ya
pas parce qu'il faut mépriser les voyait
juste auront b2 a aussi un fonds trian
tout en fait honneur je vous prenez pas
en fait les beaux jours vous savez pas
photo
ok donc de 2,1 à 3,3 et il refait centre
d'échangé espagnol qui est déjà jouée
hier le vent n'avait le foot ça this in
les nuits il va prendre des buts 6 mais
peut-être que pour wesley bon vieux port
dans le combat au corps à corps qu'on a
party d'abandon est ce qu'un écart ou ce
genre de deux parties j'ai l'impression
que tu vois dans la petite finale de
tout à l'heure il en avait perdu il en a
gagné une médaille c'est plus le type de
parti qui vit mondiale ne se passe pas
grand chose ça va ces pièces tout cas
pour le moment il fait bien fait bonne
impression aux angoisses rien puisque 3
3 en 5 1 on s'y attendait pas forcément
pas s'envoyer il le tient bon sens va
même c'est lui qui avait plutôt
davantage à chaque fois il a même d'un
zéro il a mené 2 1 à la propose de jouer
dans la survie dans le tchat
pardon mais t'es tu regardes bas camelot
tu connais peut-être pas faillir
souvient soubie deux soumis trois subi
quatre mois après j'ai pas qu'on arrive
à un multiple de chez plus quels
chiffres tu recommences qu'enfin fou
c'est les jeux de perceval de mémoire un
faut regarder camelot pour connaître a
pas une des facettes séjour tous les
accès menant déjà parlé plein de m'en
parler
c'est sûrement très bien à ce que j'aime
bien plus c'est probablement la
meilleure série française de tous les
temps
mieux que ash ouais c'est plus
intéressant ce que les pro vie des
personnes âgées profondeur bon âge
j'adorais vraiment quoi mais bon c'est
juste pour se marrer évidemment mais
camelot c'est aussi pour se marrer mais
du coup c'est pas que pour se marrer
c'est un peu de profondeur
c'est du génie mais ont du coup est ce
que on peut faire bouger pions
j'aimerais essayer de placer le cavaly
cac par angers 6 et 7 ou ru chailly
recettes ya une gym h quand même le chat
peut-être car il y en a cinq alors après
ou 5
attention il ya aussi ce qui arrive mais
coûteux trop hâtivement sur hit pour la
marque l'histoire
le cavalier va trouver un point d'appui
je voulais les charges ici vous faire
gagner mais ce paletot quoi que tu es
sûr que tu as pas le temps aux cadres il
six tours f53 g7 et il n'a pas le temps
de gagner 5
ils attendent nos échanges détour
prolongé cinq ouais mais tu te
rapproches
ce que tu vas pouvoir refaire peut-être
wife sept cavaliers aussi ça prêt à les
replacer donc a valu réussi je veux dire
brooks doit se tenir mais préfère l'un
peut voir les blancs kong et peut
vouloir jouer sur desalle à tout moment
avec son fou bas un pion sur g5 toujours
sur noir je sais pas du tout rêve cette
si tu peux considérer que la finale de
pièces mineurs tient assez bien joué le
sûrement se doit parce qu'ils montrent
trois ça va je sais pas mais bon ok on
va après l'otan après faut aussi dire
qu'en blitz dans ces finales là le
cavalier c'est toujours planter une
fourchette dans l'autre ou duda il était
foutue là avec qualité de moi tu allais
quand même réussi à planter son une
fourchette un moment donné est géré par
là que peut-être en blitz du coup c'est
pas toi d'en supprimer un truc de pro
ben en fait pas quelques victoires en
plus que tu aurais pas en longues
vraiment c'est peut-être pansard est
mieux pour les blancs mais peut-être un
poil moins graves et après c'est chiant
quand même se ranger 4 ha ouais ça
m'inquiète un peu plus la main après
menace rien parlement mais bon ça va
venir
mamans élevant de sa tour demain il va
s'envoler pour chaque baril mais assez
peut-être tour 7 en fait d'ailleurs le
montrent ces photos raw 6 tours f6
mouche ou c7 méchant ce super g 5 c'est
fini ça m'a un peu relou il s'en vend
beaucoup ce simple jeu
je pensais finit pas pourquoi quelqu'un
mais bon je possède trop chiant t'as pas
le choix
bon ils rendront plus ou moins genre
truc c'est ça il va attaquer ce que deux
des trois lots piora je suis inquiète
beaucoup
rien d'un côté tu peux restaurant h7
s'il ira pas plus loin non mais du coup
notre eau est bloqué et le roi blanc
commence à courir là bas ça une mauvaise
tête mais c'est peut-être pas fini cette
donne quand même peu de chance tu peux
aller les recettes aussi mais bon le
truc c'est quand tu as fait rage 6 3 f 5
après il menacera fou et si c'est ok il
faudrait donc pas mal en cauchies et b4
donc qui est des 4 maintenant ils
redonnent leur endroit
si tu peux pas mais au québec en
peignoir heureusement weck a hissé
ressources foulard faut faire gaffe
wells a bordeaux on se doit de gagnant
un prêt ambitions à la choisit f5 je
sais pas pourquoi tout que c'est un bon
petit les portes kg ça que je me suis
juste h6 mais voilà sur kg cet échec qui
va faire quoi
geroy les cinq oui part de l'autre côté
bon ok bon ça luxe où il a gagné 1 6
point de vue terribles pour le moral
mais je suis assez pessimiste quant à
ses chances de survie dans cette finale
nous roi blanc est beaucoup plus actif
il le fou qui est sûr qu cavaliers tous
les avantages meilleur vieillesse
mineurs meilleure structure de pions
meilleur potentiel d'europe
en fait c'est le cas ils parent h saint
qui peut même le laisser fin est passé
avec le roi derrière le roi et le
cavalier auront jamais temps de revenir
tous les dents je sais de pièces cours
portait donc ça m'a l'air d'être finie
bien sûr qu'elle ait des trois il refait
fou des deux bon cheval trop si ça et
c'est royal 3 4 way qui avait allégé de
voir en 3 kg 3 si normalement
en plus il est en plus le roi blanc
preuve d'allant 17 des 6 ou quoi cet
être qui tenta à 5 ici mais bon à 5
après il y aura du food et 2 du show
c'est seul je ne sais pas quoi
sûrement juste du storage part et c'est
sûr que crs c'est juste pour tenter un
truc quoi white est bon mais mme roy qui
met six mois là-bas peut-être s'y attend
de faire b5 et d'échangé et changer quoi
qui c'est méchant sous des deux c'est le
plus fort je suis d'accord c'est ça être
assez violent si on prend 1,4 chabbert
qui accueille trois des cinq et un truc
à ne pas oublier qu'on a un bon piont h
c'est un pion de la bande avec nous tous
évidemment tu as un truc et regarder
parce que si on s'était sacrifié le pion
d après ce sens il avait pas le choix de
faire autre chose
non non il tente la raison c'est
possible 22 source troupes et clément
après bon le cas je pense que juste il
faut avoir une bonne précision et
quelques très vite on l'avait déjà vu
faire chaque jour et dans les puzzles
dans les machins mais au moins écoute il
tente sa chance
mais je ne vois pas bien comment
maintenir non mais les bons choix seul à
vraiment prendre
ah ouais ok je l'avais même pas afficher
un ceinturon c'était long processus deux
simples les b 4 évidemment sur les
histoires de ce qui a pu passer en force
mais ce que c'est si bon ballon et de
faire confiance aux prétendues élections
ça pas mal pris ce prises à trois il va
faire pousser un à deux fois deux voies
dégagées on va prendre ces six là pas
trop si je veux bien d'abord enfin vous
avez ou je sais pas vous mais a bien
hâte rohff c1 qui est fou c'est un ses
forces et je pense que je vois pas peur
des chiens auxquels la femme à deux je
pense c'est bourrin wef médoc et à 4
fois c'est ça alors donc et son idée
c'est que si tu fais à 8 tu te feras
pour choquer 4 6 et 4 à 7 mai ces trois
français trois son voile a quand même
une justice répondait 4 ouais c'est pour
ça qu'il prend des 4 ok fou prend ceux
des quatre et c5 donc ne fait ça il
pousse il verrait son roi b de d2 à
l'image fait mal mais je me suis
toutefois très tôt qu'est-ce qu'il est
fort bon ça relou il est fort en
belgique un autre moi je me faisais
chier sous verre mais enfin je m'en
restait un bug j'espère comme jeu chez
moi mais j'ai la position aussi maison
impressionnant n'a car la finale c'est
une belle finale
baja belle finale le match et une belle
finale et c'était une belle finale
la partie quand fins et définir de
partout n'ont rien à dire on n'a rien
pour l'instant bonne finale la partie
d'avant
bon faudrait égaliser sont juste pour
rester à flot il peut gagner avec les
blancs ils ont peut pas dire que d'un
cadre domine vraiment ce début de match
assez équilibré pour le moment et si sow
égaliser ce serait plutôt logique un
d'être à quatre partout là ouais mais
bon après faut être opportuniste
messieurs il faut être opportuniste ou 3
ouais bon je ferai ma tour vous je pense
a pas mis en eux deux pour éviter
cependant se faire attaquer sur tempo
avec kf4 magie mais après j'ai pas trop
que mondiale a notre mot un bon
peut-être ces quatre copines des quatre
pas mal aussi hein parce que peut-être
on va faire un jour tourner un tour b 3
tours prend à 3 après l'es4 bouffier
dick advocaat a juste cinq ans m donc tu
vas le faire directe et illégale donc ça
monde n'hésite bien défendre de cinq
attaques b4g poupe tête retour à b1 et
qui est des 424 cac et prend des quatre
îles des bons ils montrent un peu comme
ces quatre je pense qu'un onglet 3 1 et
2 comme bhp ne sont pas mal d'amis ces
cartes acca viderait de 22,5 à ta dam
des bassins brède au coeur d'un souci
mais bon comme ces quatre cahiers 17
mieux faire qu'ils s'impliquent tempo
bon c'est un gros souci mais il va faire
en tout cas voilà mesdames b36 légaliser
cinq dossiers étaient beaux et surtout
race et un peut-être que tu peux pas
aller bouffer ans et 7 après quelques
cinq s'il ya des trois qui traîne
mais bon d'un côté une fois que racaille
on a eu cinq hectares a fait dame b3 du
coup tu auras f 4 5 fois oui non ça
coûte mesure d'être pas si mal pour
wesley vous provence se trouve à cause
d'un truc concret c'est bien pour la
mare mais manière générale j'aime bien
écrit blandine alors je ne sais pas s'il
faut quand même prendre si cette turquie
et prend des troncs fera tourner un au
québec menace f4 f5 aussi enfin il ya le
cavalier emprisonnés mais à cette f4 eu
5 f 5 mois la fuite
irene bon ok j'ai trois fois de plus de
son grand chose donc temps de le bouger
7 5
peut-être se libère la case de 4 en fait
pour le cavalier au 5 et qu'il y ait
bougé d'amel fuite peut-être non tam t7
il empêche f5 taquerias sarkozy via
tours et freins ou quoi mais bon kituro
4 nature et calme bien joué parce que
l'autre tout reviendra sur et fin du
coup et tu presses des cas donc mieux
mieux mieux que mon tour et freins ta
tête l'idée de faire tourner ses quatre
tours prend des quatre aussi cavalier e
de aussi d'ailleurs peut être jouable
tu protèges f4 attaques des quatre
s'attaque vraiment sur tous les azimuts
ouais c'est impressionnant c'est
tellement millimétré ouais et puis tu as
aussi l'idée peut-être f 5,6 peut-être
en force majeure c'est tellement du jeu
de sur tout le périmètre de l'échiquier
s'est pas cantonnée à une aile et tous
et toutes atacado jeu contre attaque à
droite les pièces qui passe d'un côté à
l'autre c'est hyper dur mais c'est dur à
jouer il ya donc sur béziers se faire
tour c6 simplement et madame c4 ici
alors il joue bien je veux bien rester
[Musique]
tarkovski 'sinon il a fait quoi que a
commis en mai jusque là et je veux pas
ce truc chouette mais pourquoi simpson
ça si je jouais à cocody est bon mais il
jouer les qualifs non d'attendre
pourquoi parce que il fait des trucs sur
la chaîne youtube de saint louis je
pense y'a pas de dame prend aussi si si
qui est la sphère bandé 8 probablement
mais peut-être s'en fout bonne qualité
ont poussé simple qu'on pousse par trop
bon après pourquoi pas juste repartent
avec la tour en même temps pour qu'on
donne au dunk gates et je sais pas
jordan d'élite même tour ces quatre
mêmes probablement c'est bien joué je
pense dam des scintillements la
canadienne 5 ou 10 mois je voudrais de
dame prend 40 reprend 2,4 mais cavaliers
c'est avec la direccte c'était hyper
fort voilà commun devient tout le
solaire tous âges
non tu gagnes une pièce non ok il fera
d'amd 8 mai bon set qu'elle prend 1,6
après
ok français c'est votre chance il vous
reprendrez 1,8 au bluff mais je crois
qu'elle va faire un tour b de machin
week et progressait tu as la dame comme
direct ça ne crois pas 39 milliards d'un
procès sur fond de 6 3 et 2 ouais mais
kg 6 échecs la bombe à ce moment là bas
que je crois en mon nom est présente au
point cet ail défend maintenant on sait
si cet art prend des quatre attention
aussi société mieux les contres jeu trop
depuis ce temps mais pourquoi il a fait
tomber deux bons sûrement pas grand
chose votre santé de nous taper g2 il a
peut-être essayé de mettre le pion au f5
sur tourbe et deux on va quand même vite
avec nos options a tout fait rire fils
cadet à tomber deux dames c'est 2 1
je crois qu'en accordant les fuites d'un
objet 4 selon genre la dame est sa
deviens tu cette hyper logique mais bon
ok j'ai réussi dame prend à trois un
truc c'était le truc a pas joué de 9,7
sur quatre une défense dessus aidé à me
prends à droite en live quoi dans mes
projets mais au moins à 7,8 et on bloque
quand même pas mal de contre je n'ai où
on a des ghettos matériel ne me
prendront dans les voitures neuves en
2008 ok moi un temps c'est sûrement le
plus principal parce que je suis faire
recette
8 évidemment 800 bloqués et qu'on les
rassure je t'avais 5 mg/kg ça sur tourbe
et d'audace et de menaces les matins
échecs dames g4 bonne nouvelle je pense
qu'il peut gagner c'est bon ok bravo 3 3
4 4
quand même équilibre rien donc est-ce
qu'on va pas prendre des changes de
spanair et si ça berlinois c'est me sens
dans mon âme plein air bag avait rien
obtenu il ya non ces six ou sept
c'est très serré en vigueur mais aucun
match nous attend mais cjrs que ce soit
a ajouté mme pauline enfin il a même pas
besoin de réfléchir il a dû réviser sa
mélo de jouer avec les deux couleurs oui
c'est sûr mais je repars irradiante us
réviser sa juste avant battus à tout le
monde s'attendait à une boucherie c'est
pas du tout une boucherie à ce que s'il
sort fait nul ici avec les blancs il a
quand même pressé j'ai l'impression dans
toutes les parties après il s'est lui
fait actifs y est mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il a toujours un peu pressé limogne
développe je suis pas sont maintenant ma
vie crin qui n'instruit ben et je vous
ai chaque agréable ce soir n'était le
format qui veut ça il ya quelqu'un qui
nous ici téluq et youth mais qu'ils sont
choqués ils lancent une pétition pour
que tu te remets jeter dans le centre
pas de jour de thénac ap
bah vu que c'est pas eux qui décident
venait me chercher
non mais bon très bien rester sont donc
toute imposition
latifi mme way peut être s'il est ici
mais j'ai envie de dire latinistes de
platine ont tourné cette c5 je pense bon
jeu saw ces genres de finale où
normalement il est chaud ouais mais bon
je vous ai déjà bizarre dans les
septièmes je crois sur dame des 3l a pas
fais d'un rêve c'est là le problème
habitué à voir quelque chose à vous vois
pas quoi te regarde alors dit qu'on y
pense
bon retour des 8 stations taxis en fait
tu force la torah c'est changer celui
qui attend prend 1,7 sur non c'est juste
de me des quatre qui va arriver
problème du roi qui est en france est
fragile dont 3,7 et auquel adam preuve
cette tour des huit damme jean roch aime
ton rêve d'un mais celle ci a fait
retour f70 j'ai dit sur un territoire à
s'introduire 2 en v2 et tu mets le pion
c5 et échanger ces nuls face il ya 139 g
voilà c'est ça mais ça avance que ce
soit il prend son temps à tuer ils se
disent qu'il ya pas mieux peut-être tu
vas wen dans des genres quoi c'est dur
de voir mieux où tu as comme un mec quoi
tu penses d'autres quelques justes tout
jusqu'au bout et encore 3013 1 il a le
temps mais c'est ça mais je sais pas ce
qui a été payant ne va rien à voir mais
en fait les chanceux qui sont restés sur
la chaîne visserie me comprennent pas
que ils comprennent pas qu'on marche
twitch en fait s'ils comprennent pas
qu'on lit le chat de la vraie chan fait
sur les crêtes et streamé travail du
coup ça te fait de chat
[Musique]
mais c'est correct et on est chez ascom
en fait tu as l'impression de tout genre
et expliquer la même chose c'est
horrible ouais donc posé on explique sur
balles à juin d'expliquer en fait
expliqué par écrit non non mais bon j'ai
dit ils payent ils écoutent comme les
autres tu sais il fallait sur le switch
duchess com fr non c'est écrit
normalement sur le hosting en fait sur
le haut du stream atteindra finale de
psion ça doit arguer il y aura un poil
plus actifs
si ça ce qui pour pearn cinquième match
assez ce que 10 petits vauriens c'est
pourtant il ya tout le temps le lien au
dessus tu vois c'est genre écrit en gros
quoi j'ai dit que normalement ce n'est
pas trop dur quoi 5
[Musique]
je peux seulement attaques soient
majorées fait mais je suis chasseur sans
un bon coup et vous on est bien au signe
l'un que l'autre a valu aussi docile que
nous ça nulle somme nulle
il a fâché avec les amis il est nul
ils l'ont trouvé où ce joueur
drobo met à 30 euros tu le trouve sur
les marchés
slave est restée les amis c'est génial
quand ils disent c'est la vérité et ses
5 g singer cat bouffe ps s'inquiète cinq
bouts frappe 6 aura des 5 pouces rendre
machin sans temps de regarder il faut
faire autre chose maxime tu dois être
pas tous champions cc6 pas mal cette
ferme située 3 et 6 3 et si tu as fait
un petit muret la foulée blanche pas ce
qui est sûr c'est que nous on l'aurait
perdu déjà bon moi je serais heureux 2 6
mhz un appareil sera c4 au caire avait
quatre et je fais trois des cinq
ouais parce que je regardais reprend à
4'' hurricanes 4
les sound gfl synovate a gardé un petit
muret autre côté c'est bien ce petit
muret au début avant de repartir
sentenac
enfin petit truc tiens mais je pense que
tu bouges pas mais il peut essayer très
le pion pas à ses actes mais je pense
que dans ces cas là tu peux envoyer le
con tre jeu avec des 5 à 5 des quatre ce
que le tuant à 4 il est bien placé quand
tu rentres dans la finale ses pions à
combustion à ce que ton roi du coup il
court assez vite verser 8
s'il reste l'option as tu vois c'est
vrai ces affaires b5 et c5 b4 quand bien
même il réussit à faire on apprend ces
cinq bab à tord et le temps de recouvrer
roi des rois e63 prend 1,4 wade c'est 3
b st croix c'est 8 tu vois et donc après
ça la fab ce sera la dernière partie de
5 + 1 normalement hockey de sept minutes
donc c'est une 2e il va pas les avoir
dans cette partie en revanche partie
suivante on devrait arriver aux sept
minutes de jeu
vraisemblablement médaille à 7 minutes
donc soit il opte à part après cela ce
sera la dernière normalement je pense
pas trop me trompe planté est ce que ça
ne va pas durer sept minutes celle là
bas là je vois mal ce qu'ils vont
continuer pour l'instant mais on va voir
qui c'est personne ne sait ok bon il
faut calculer il suffit bessin qui fait
roi des quatre et c5 roi des 5 3 5 roi
c6 réserve fédérale montrent une une
voix nul mais en tant que sapeur en fait
peut-être fallait pas faire au roi des
rois quatre fois et afpa faire 3 au 6
mai arrêt dans mes tableaux je sais pas
très pudique où attendait donc ok alors
si c'est un creux de sa main propre un 5
3 6 6 4 lors des quatre à pouvoir garder
on écoute mon père est ce qu'on sait
qu'à 3 à 4 c 3 bouffe bouffer roi des
singes est un droit des trois à quatre
et sur des cinq rois des cas trois c4
or alive 5 croit ces cinq partout
batsheva joues pas tu roules bien fini
mais du coup je sais pas où il s'est
planté
oui c'est peut-être pas planter du tout
ceci mais teamteam tout il n'envoie le
lien de notre française et kitsch est ce
là avait la raison merci mais ce qui est
permis ou en a qui l'ont prise ce truc
bon alors à temps il rentre on est entre
on a regardé et on pense est perdante
ok peut-être qu'il peut essayer de jouer
roi des cinq machin fait roi des 6 3 des
5 et jouer le deux contre un mais doit
être perdante de contrats privés voire
un souk sent que c'est sûr que ces
perdants
je vois pas comment ça pourrait tenir sa
femme va tomber en plus nous apprend
wayne on sait rien à faire non mais non
voyons un phishing est bizarre on
appelle ça la récession' à l'adoption du
fonds ce qu'elle était perdant délai dès
le début juste à cause de l'espace est
ce que c'est possible de faire quoi
qu'elle était perdante juste perdante
bah franchement il mais c'est peut-être
un des coups je sais pas bah en fait
c'est parce que c'est justement fin
c'est que c'est important à droite yves
dans les finales mais toi je pensais que
c'était pas assez pour que soient
gagnants mais c'était à priori sans
calcul et vous savez la tête d'un truc
qui devait faire nul ça vient de voir
je suis étonné mais bon enfin c'est
possible que c'était gagnant enfin il y
avait davantage des spasmes et avantages
des espaces an mal an c'est pas énorme
non mais bon des courroies actifs machin
ça suffit
voilà
intéressant
du coup bon ça on a déjà eu assez
souvent dans ce genre position attend
c'est le débat du parc absents qui
jouent tous à bas tous deux 20 ouais
mais là on a un truc qui ressemble et
plus ou moins enfin ce n'est pas tout à
fait ça mais on est une structure
ouais je veux plus y toucher 5 lorient
non mais non avant-hier non le samyn là
on me jetait pologne ouais il envisage
la voie légale plus ou moins n'hésitez
pas exactement ce position mais ça
ressemble avec des échanges en russie
mais je préfère toujours arriveront dans
ce genre de truc mais après je sais pas
quel point tu es mieux ou c'est juste
visuellement ce cadre comme tourcoing f3
ici cavaler h4 ça peut être bon sait-on
leur alléger m'écoute si ça marche ça
marche tu peut-être faire tout retourné
j'ai vu anglet peut-être sera en longue
je comprends que méambly tu vois d'un
point de vue pratique est ce que wayne
ans c'est un peu léger par les tours et
8 me suis un vrai bon si ça marche je
serai un peu surpris ça me semblerait
léger aussi mais en plus il ya un truc
pour défendre certains cas livres 5 qui
a très bien moins cléments avec l'âge
alors peut-être ça va suffire bien
défendre là il s'est barré naka pour le
vent est plus sur sa chaise pour tuche
irait il n'a pas tenu une heure et demie
passée la dernière partie de la cadence
clairement il reste une minute 47
parties va durer plus d'une minute 40 c
sur les nac nac à qui il faudra dire
avec just came short arrivons en tête to
go to thrill est un contrôle de one hour
swing states minutes spot de la soul to
you were to wrap for me regarde je dis
donc en anglais je fais la fosse en
armes ou de naka
oui oui je peux devenir bataille wine to
play puzzle rush fort force lumineuse
highway to put my world tour en
remportant deux matchs où êtes vous
parvenu ou pas noëlla il est arrivé en
courant il est revenu il remet son
casque il part tout cas il chaussait et
j'ai une grimace directement paul schaaf
s'est plaint de grimaces là tout d'un
coup il a fait peut-être 3,4 grimace
d'affilée bon retour aux 3 aller
ailleurs grimaces de partout la csfy bon
dos pour son faut défendre deux tours et
fins qu'une marque tous à tour à deux
pas et ça c'est génial qui est un mec
qui qui viennent à sa place et cuit qui
part à la chasse perd sa place
enfin rihanna et tu peux plus jouer le
match brandon prust soit ou pas ou
d'hommes ces deux jeux suivants
excellent même si ça eu des quais et des
quatre pas mal en inde au petit tremplin
des cinq ans regarde ses sept tours
c'est bon bon bon allez être on prend
1,5
pour ces trois joueurs à l'essai à
doubler tour bon j'aime bien je préfère
les blancs conducteur mais ça reste
tendue
non il y aura une feuille puis très vite
les noirs d'être active est embêté mais
je sais pas c'est bien ces colonnes
siècle
quand même un petit avantage à total et
à cake venir ericsson chez on me parle
et est de prononcer cette pâture suite à
la fin il n'a pas le temps de quelques
as voyages 5 surtout ses 8 balles de
match une à 9-8 ouais ça pas passer ça
passe pas mais même des 5 lots se
regardent et peut-être de basta pas très
envie de la case c5 suprême 7 en force
c'est cet enfer jonah hill a pris ok on
savait qu'il y prend de basware bizarre
d'avoir pris mais sert à rien de concret
derrière hockey pendant un autre côté
peut-être qu'il veut
moi je suis tu vois bon notre quête des
f-5 quoi la crimée à skis et h5
maintenant puis peut-être c'est un jour
en bon terme pouvoir s'occuper de ce
truc
il peut tout couvrir avec damev 7 mai
normes la f4 qui va arriver c'est bien
ça serait bien qu'ils égalisent 5,5 ça
pas mal on regardera le truc allez on
pousse qu'on a ce sera assez logique
g6 bon si c'est à mon avis la dessus du
but que ça marchait pas c'est peut-être
juste en fait avec le québec donc ils
s'accrochent les bons codes sauf
peut-être à 10h 4h 5h le mans pour les
blancs pour revenir vers 5 h 5 lui même
il faut qu'ils réussissent à se
solidifier sa vie mais peut-être touré
femme une sage quatre milieux de on n'a
pas trop où seuls deux ans fred 4 mais
on dégage ce qu'elle est centrale
il faut le dégager de façon
qui va s'opérer la case de 4,1 ça gigote
gennaker d'un mec car j'ai l'impression
de quoi ces deux va être mieux mais
tellement difficile pratiquement de
réaliser davantage mais c'est la preuve
qu'on à chaque jour contre maca convoi
il se démène médias bon j'ai le souvenir
d'il ya deux ou trois ans quand maxime
jouer contre lui les matches mais que
des fois tu vois que tu es mieux mais je
sais pas il se met à jouer vite et que
moi peu désagréable dur est fait ici
c'est pas mal hein mais s'il serait bien
jouer d'un cas qui a fait l'amour
n'était pas content il ya eu des super
si ce n'est peut-être vu comme moi je
pensais que fric tu as un truc c'est de
type tour j'ai 3 pour revenir de l'autre
côté far kg 5 et 6 mai b6 est hyper fort
il met la pression sur le pion des six
qui a attaqué f1 qui attaquaient way qui
est sous pression et quand tu fais b
c'est une assez huit dames donc si la
tour d'en revenir ans et 8 c'est clair
que c'est horrible pour les noirs mais
wesley qui s'en sort 1
voilà prendre ces sept bons même là il
peut il pas n'est pas juste or et noir
si beau pioncer cette grève s'arrête
juste à gagner - je crois que oui bon il
faut deux choses bon petit post pour 5 5
on est content c'est équilibré c'est
bien le fils à la physionomie du match
c'est cool bonne route
les parties de 3,3 ce serait bien qu'on
arrive en bullet avec un peu de
décisions qu'ils apprennent que pourra
je prends un petit pot joué dans les
cinq minutes vous allez à tout de suite
oui c'est très indécis pour le moment
très indécis mais on peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas dire que qu'un des deux
joueurs
et mérité de mener c'est un score somme
toute logique ce 5,5 et ça reste très
ouvert qu'aux matchs en plus ça continue
plus égale ça joue sur moins de parti et
- ya deux parties - ya deux parties plus
il ya de deux possibilités de créer des
surprises c'est comme quand on tout sur
un match tout peut arriver donc pour le
moment plutôt une bonne c'est bonne
heure et demie de sort pas du tout
dominé par maka
donc plutôt plutôt positif pour le
moment pour cent
medic paris se fait malmener
mais paris qui mène 2 1 je vais regarder
ça va mais c'est serré un tout peut
arriver
ouais c'est vraiment impressionnant même
ce soir et l'impressionnant donc c'est
pas étonnant qu'il ait réussi à battre
la batoude a finalement vendredi parce
qu'il réussit à tenir contre naka et
tenir compte rona 45 + 1 n'y a pas grand
monde qui peut le faire on l'a bien vu
dans l'esprit chess précédent mise à
part
magnus et maxime et maxime qui a fini
par craquer mais qui avait tenu un
certain moment il y a personne d'autre
qui a été capable de le tenir donc c'est
vraiment une belle une belle performance
de la part de deux sauts pour le moment
après le gros problème ce serait
évidemment le bullet
est ce que m l'évaluation de
l'ordinateur en direct on ne le fait pas
on veut pas le faire parce que ça ça
nous paraît un peu tué le l'intérêt
quand est-ce que ça reprend là ça va
reprendre dans deux minutes maximum je
pense
donc ça va être dur le le segment 2 1 +
1 c'est celui qui doit être le payeur
pour sommer bon pour le moment il joue
aussi vite que n'a qu'a donc possible
on va voir
on va voir way to die du manque et les
ouvertures
donc ça va repartir assez soin sous peu
fade qui est de retour et là je crois
que les joueurs aussi sont en train de
se réinstaller d'un cas est revenu au
cash flow tour soit un retour aussi on a
vu ce qui est venu qui est reparti mais
ça devrait ça y est il en train de
s'asseoir et de voir son chat quoi
peut-être qu'elles sont jamais très
intéressant bon allez ça va repartir
du coup comme ça c'est un chat aux yeux
bleus mais tu veux le voir en photo mais
changer vraiment rose qui te félicite
pour la couverture du championnat du
monde
je sais pas je pense était pas mal mais
bon j'ai pas mal de problèmes techniques
surtout pendant le dans le truck
l'espace est un peu indépendante au 20e
vastes achats car sans elle et son joli
lac les yeux bleus wei sympa chat de
personnes il y est doux et lolli 123 et
du coup est ce que les le fait d'aller
aux toilettes alors écoutez la dernière
partie à la gare va peut-être de fonds
suspects entre elles auraient pu
résister plus longtemps quoi dommage de
craquer à 2008 et de prendre un bidon
comme le cycliste même tu puisses devant
leur dire on voit pas quoique aimerait
donc
bon c'est pas bien j'en sais rien et
donc je sous-estiment sur leur position
pas prévu je me dis ok north juste très
bien aller en fait c'est peut-être le
même truc que du fait qu'en fait comme
tu obtiens rien nulle part peut-être que
ça c'est mieux que que plus rien d'autre
part qu'est-ce que dire ouais bon moi tu
peux jouer c'est pas égalisé en position
empire c'est juste égal mais tu peux
jouer des finales des machins donc
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas écoute fois ci
seraient ces trucs classiques pour
essayer de gagner la colonne cbc les
foudres winstein quoi ok mais tu vois
c'est là le point 5 ans non mais je
pense que là il a tenu sommet tu vois tu
as toujours ce petit pas avantage c'est
pas un avantage mais donc des trucs à
surveiller tout est vrai par exemple
qu'avec les noirs tu peux manquer de
précision et de faire rentrer sur une
colonne tiote la même si tu fais genre
foot français broient pris ce prix de
rsa ok tu dois encore vérifier là je
pense ça va maintenant le roi arrive en
hausse est oui tiens tiens tout gaz un
traître 1h17 ou je sais pas quoi ici non
bref feria qui a et b 5 encore dans
l'autre à huit vous et ça va aller mais
était encore en trouver deux trois trucs
prend dès 400 iso monsieur je pense que
ça va faire mieux
laquelle est ensuite tu veux prendre
prendre qu'à eux et b5 et b6 et qu'il ya
cette fois tu vas toujours sur les
intentions mais roy c'est ça pourquoi
pas ce match va partir c'est aussi
qu'elle a je pense qu'on arrive par la
zone où c'est complètement égal tel g5
ça peut être facile à l'entourage 5 g 5
contre 4 mais côte bon faut savoir que
les finales d'europe gagnée pour les
noirs tout cas dans ces structures
robin stein notammnent orange 3 après
faut y arriver
abbas oui avec changer des pièces phares
éteints je crois mais crown et quand on
la gagne comme ça
ci-contre salem un besoin qui a dit que
d'une 14e théâtre où ça va essayer de
faire qui est biblique et 6,6 et paf
alors bon là maintenant que je suis sur
mes pulls avantage blanc mais bon pour
être là par les avantages la routine ans
et tu te régales pas grand chose à faire
il faut juste pas se mettre trop
longtemps et 30 secondes d'écart bon
écoute une 30 c'est encore beaucoup pour
wesley mme tapas vous trouvez le temps
pas faire comme les bannières et des
fois juste part à cause de la pendule
pour ces deux lieux où ça tient jusqu'à
et des quatre éco son fils sean lamont
mais sow il est méga pragmatique tu as
enfin il fut tour à tour machin tour ses
six noms mais bien parce que ta vie il
bouge pas en fait sauce et c'est pas mal
ce qui fait peur c'est pas facile à
faire psychologiquement t il fait
tourner ses cinq tours à chaque course
et 5 sur 6 6 sur 6 5 tours h 5 tours
c'est un retour c'est 6 bat fallait
avoir envie de rien de rien comme ça
mais vous dépassez jusqu'à 9 heures mais
c'est pas évident évidemment c'est dur a
offert en écoute mon sort au port dans
les mêmes machin on va retrouver la
structure il a changé c'est pas le truc
qui avait joué à une vl ça le foot et 5
à la coupe du monde
ouais bon c'était pas cette position
tout à fait je pense mais l'astuce était
sûr à 6 puis à 5 on va se tenir à l'idée
des grilles tchouki tu dois apprendre
du coup et c'est là qu'il y avait à 4
jouer m'acharne annonce était pas tout à
fait la position mais c'est validé
oui bon ça peut changer le fou et la
suite leurs livres de chefs dans le
livre
il parle de b3 aussi de façon parfois
6,6 des changes même et tu prends de
blizzard quoi quelque part mais écoute
attendez vous une à la cera kat mais
comptent renforcer sur bombay et 11
septembre
je pense qu objectivement ça va pour ça
je pense aussi parce que mis à part avec
4,6 facilement quoi c'est plutôt
peut-être même les blancs qui vont
attaquer à la loi au final jordan d2 je
fais du roi 3 h à un tour j'ai un bon
temps mais il allait beaucoup mieux si
quelque part c'est toi qui est un pion
plus à l'est le roi liche pas est ce que
tu peux faire f 4 6,6 ou pas mais bon
rien offert de h cup en tout cas de son
choix moitié soit 15 4 et 5 jeudi
et puis on a potentiellement un deuxième
pion aux élèves qui peuvent non f4 pour
pouvoir la case 5 s'il ya besoin
d'amener de d'abord par contre je sais
pas prévu de calculer ce qui est plus
précis dont il fait même des deux
c'est difficile un ses positions à jouer
après c'est pas simple monsieur meghout
c'est sûrement beaucoup mieux pour le
mans pas se faire arnaquer machin là
c'est vite dit ne pas savoir mac et
merkel h4 nombreux il ya un côté d'un
côté femmes c'est vidy d'un autre côté
ils ont le niveau va se faire arnaquer
bref 3
je pense qu'ils larguent le pion il veut
faire vite tour et fait un tour j'ai
deux là j'imagine un et a pris très vite
la décision de le faire rentrer chez eux
mais c'est intéressant en fait au prix
d'un futur avec tous tes problèmes
pratiques
je trouve que mon tu le vends plus donc
le temps néanmoins way est fier juste et
pion double et une règle le problème du
pion à f4 et puis tout d'un coup un
tatoo rejet 2 qui avec 5 mais tu as ça
c'est un truc parce que j'aurais juste
jamais pensé moi perso mais pas pour une
fraction de seconde demie d'entretien
non mais on est d'accord peut-être en
partie donc je trouve ça ça je sais pas
mais là on oublie de se faire ça en
l'espace de cinq secondes de tu vois les
intérieurs maric le cerveau il veut
tellement vite il faut qu'il le jeu sans
réfléchir
mais là il doit être juste super bien
parce que tu attaques des schistes une
menace les trucs la colonne jeu comme la
saint louis on comprend ce soir fait si
on comprenait pas et tout d'un coup à
dire comme tout le monde quoi tuer le
nouveau vice fischer qui a eu cet été
france et 8e une option qui est prend
des six aussi morano butscher je pense
pas non mais bien sûr que non mais
c'était pour reparler du fameux truc de
finn gold ou the king la tour g1 direct
six tours j'ai un salary performances
dans le temps eide avait ce soir là j'ai
vu à de base et puis après j'ai raté mes
moyens
bien bien bien faire de 5 après un
concert one bâle 3 joueurs c'est partie
de la salle où il a juste franck tu me
fasses pensez vous avez déjà oublié
j'y pensais plus mais qu'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est impressionnant en contre mais
c'est génial on fait avec ce que fait
digne très rapide mais bon blazy oui
j'étais capable de faire nul qua non
mais ok il a vu son énorme broche
finalement gagné tous été constant 2010
s'attend pas non mais tu sais vlad
parfois il faut juste l'impressionner
avec les ouvertures avec un truc il
analyse la faune ou je sais pas tu vois
des fouilles peut être impressionné par
des trucs qui impressionne personnes
mais qui est vraiment impressionnant
mais juste une édition dans son nom dans
leur monde un peu du haut niveau là
qu'un peu ou pas je trouve ça assez
spécifique comme mon nom oui la regarde
l avare en critiques
will quatre jours à comprendre oui c'est
ça en fait ouais mais c'est quand même
avec jude a en fait où ils peuvent pas
comment peux tu joue aussi mal fait il
était en pls hamadjoda comment tu ne
connais pas à ça bon ok enfin fou oui il
a bien évidemment sont comme moi avaient
analyse alors dit c'est que c'est +0 59
3 je pense mais vous mangez trop après
où j'ai pas un truc comme ça mais bon c
4 c'est pas un truc aussi 4 pas mal
j'aime bien on laisse ce chou b6 en
panique
c'est la partie où il fait que de
rentrer du matériel que les champions de
plus sa qualité enfin je te rends même
monde et c'est qu'avant depuis cinq des
six et puis très fort car c'est très
bien jouer une nouvelle fois pour pour
les
pour les internautes sur quatre envois
trip sion cette fête commence j'ai
demandé est ce que tu vas commencer
parfois f2 pour éviter ça chibane matin
ouais mais c'est un cas échéant leucate
le quai des 600 faut aussi il faut aussi
ses fondements bayer l'assaut un il fait
son match
c'est la panique celtique pourri car il
se dit le vent souffle lmp2 c'est
bizarre entre de la montagne américaine
quoi et très chaud quoi je chante
maintenant
ouais mais ce que je disais à la blague
en effet un remix l'iseca simlement
seconde en est venu me chercher
on était très chaud elle en a fait tout
un remix l'autre soir c'est pour hakim
le film de genre ouais et du coup à
l'étranger rentrent kassim cas si mon
second temps est venu me chercher j'ai
jeté un dernier rush sur la cheville
nicole on avait écrit tout un truc
fantastique nice et 6,6 large et pas une
haute opinion de demandes de nos cas où
tu vas se faire d un demi tonneau
non moi je peux pas dire comme la janis
ecoinfo lors des mardis - 0,04 quoi
comment tu ne sais pas 100 membres
comment tu rentres là dedans ouais c'est
génial comme l'a dit oui il te donne
quelque chose comme +0 53 ans portant le
3 et on est ce que les proches des trois
jeux 6 0 kg 6 qui couvrent hockey
reprend 1,6 kg 6 donc et votre souci
mais si le temps de regarder rush 5 g 4
malgré obtint sa plainte mais tout va
bien tout va bien tout va bien
du coup du coup il faut juste un
cafetier suspense à la ccip logique mais
juste une chatte héniart structure de
pion à moins que pat evra f5 puisque
c'est que ça ok mais à l'effort de mise
ici veut faire d'amener sans âme soit
madame set je souhaite juste que ça
bouge et ça ne doit repartir et tu fais
tour des 8es pépère le champ plus haut
ma meilleur potentiel du monde dans ses
positions là les plus de 5 à un moment
donné tu vois c'est important c'est
notre ami un complice
hu à bombay si tu fais quoi sur tours 17
à c5 et c7
il peut pas tenant d'ailleurs pas tout à
fait repousser cette fois même si je
sais pas sait jamais si simple en fait
bizarre ok j 6 bon il veut dégager cette
dame qui est d'ailleurs entré en
dix-sept effet des dames 6 les dames
aussi c'est chaque et du coup tu fous
ces cinq verges à holmes voilà mes
regrets
c'est bien de jeu mais s'il faut pas
juste prendre des deux fers pour des
langues et tu peux prendre des deux
prend 2,3 et met pas tous rangs des huit
mètres autour des 3 me d'impôts du bon
après je veux bien croire que nulle
normalement mais il avance un peu qu'est
ce que tu vas faire ces 5
mais bon il va te refaire dam des 3 et 4
mètres l'amendé 5 donc non pas 3 dan b6
dames c'est un échec moral
ok c'est nul non faut faire gaffe quand
il ya 17 ans prise et tape à perpète
parce qu'il ya deux détenus deux
rappeurs petit jeu c'est comme ça parce
qu'elle brigue donc pourquoi chraïbi que
l'on ne pouvait pas prendre g5 ce
qu'avait fameux 6 échecs et adam prend
des six bottés voici les cobras bon à
prendre six morts et coûté dans son
combat à l'italienne petit reste il
reste 45 minutes dans la cadence y mène
d'un point pour le moment il est bien
c'est quoi alors les décadences 1h30
1h30 non en fait je lui prédis pas
compris c'est à dire c'est 1h30 de 5 + 1
une heure de 3 + 1 et 30 minutes 2 1 + 1
non mais il ya un truc bien avec tu as
comme par contre dans ce qu'ils font en
général fab
c'est que fais tu t'es quand on parlait
des partages au début du match et tout
ça rien dans les allées bondées je te
dis ça mon gros arguments contre c'était
que c'était pas compréhensible comme
format 16 points comme en fait leur
format c'est toujours logique va c'est
comme les arénas lundi mercredi vendredi
toujours à la même heure toujours deux
heures parce que je veux dire
il ya dans ce genre lundi une minute
mercredi 3 à vendredi c'est incroyable
en fait dans ce n'est ni cohérence moi
il ya souvent une cohérence dans ce
qu'ils font et tu peux déduire en fait
quelque part le
elle n'a pas dû voir que la dame était
défendu la et donc oui c'est pour ça que
ça fait une heure trente 1h30 quoi bon
comme il est moche et le tout cas
d'heure de la partie d'avant vous n'a
qu'à les lâcher un pion on va là c'est
sow qui achètent ça va pas être facile
quoi c'est un pion 2002 sous pression
tarifaire full 3d shanghai pour ces
horribles mais bon tu peux peut-être
avoir envie de faire bondir tapions bca
sous pression et peut-être fait un truc
très opportuniste là tu peux pas faire
qu'il y avait cinq épreuves quatre états
de faits caillasser chèques tout bleu
roi bon je pense que ceci soit c'est
horrible je crois qu'il boit le calice
jusqu'à la lie ouais pour un petit
miracle
donc dans la partie d'oublier qu'il
pouvait pas faire dame prend 1,4 et or
prend bien qu'adam 17 défendu par
localier psy c'est que jordan prend 17
ans reprend un échec et se retrouve
qu'une tournoi donc guaino d'adopter
chronométrie masse dans cette cadence si
longtemps encore il ya le temps quand
rice 42 minutes y ait pas encore pas mal
quand même ok ok a pris dans le cas qui
va vouloir prendre prendre et j'ai été
obligé de un mec qui fait des liens qui
machin et que je valide ailleurs
temporairement dans le chat le lien de
quoi chez pas une partie qu'on aurait
joué à nîmes
je rappelle pas avoir joué contre tout
en tournant avec possible on était gamin
je pense je compte ou nîmes j'ai jamais
joué à nîmes occasions où je sais pas
peut-être c'était j'ai pas essayé de
comprendre très longtemps ce que c'était
exactement et je vous rappelle pas qu'on
ait joué ensemble en partie près
peut-être un tournoi de blitz et des
villes ont un truc comme ça quoi on
pourrait parier une carte sim premiers
points de la saison je crois
ils ont fait 2 2 anecdotique non aux
battements
enfin c'est bien pour mathieu cornette
deuil quand on est tous très contents du
coup l'om pour jouer le titre
variété stopper on sait pas quand j'ai
vu la vidéo de momo ben enseigne on joue
le titre
il en a marre en matière voilà
n'envahisse et par raffarin mais il joue
plus le titre
bon il te faut rentrer rolandeau qu'en
fait il faut convaincre
il a un gros coup mais il aimait bien en
face au fait on parle on parle mais il
comprend pas la réaction
c'est pas nous ont toujours des scores
de foot je t'ai coton sur autre chose
non mais là il va faire les cartes mais
est ce qui a valu au 7 mai et 17 îlots
centraux bush qui apprend qu'il
prendrait 5 hockey et tours 5
tu échanges de saint calais bumba 3 4
cavaliers car quand on passe tifa 8
focalise ce cavalier quoi tu as tout
reprend b 5 au 6 mai prochain d'un pro f
4g les trois annonces a pu mais
tourcoing 8 en vue c'est sûr échec a pas
d'âme point f 4k u8 et saint béat trio
est ce qu'on peut faire c'est parce
qu'il ya un autre coup là qui succombent
à part ces sept on s'en fout quant aux
boues ne veux pas qu'il y ait de 1.8 et
la petite fourchette que 13,5 d'erdf 5,5
croquer messi gagne celle là et quatre
non tu ou peut-être 3g 3 tu t'en fous tu
as déjà ne pas la perdre
c'est quelque chose qui est faire gaffe
peut-être qualité 5 c'était une vraie
menace recueille 10 5
ouais je vois bon cette bécane quoi
c'est tellement chose finale aux
cavaliers de quéant b4 oui c'est qu'eric
à l'éclat dans l eau secours et du coup
y'a plus qu'à et des cinq maintenant non
il n'ya pas ross et 5 non plus donc
maintenant il va ramener son roi petit à
petit mais ça devrait le faire
il a bloqué deux doigts d'être pions
adverse ta chance et complètement gagné
moi j'ai trois au québec on n'a qu'à
faut faire gaffe quand même hein parce
que vous le révélions savonnerie
peut-être paroisse et 5 maintenant sur
recettes qui est et quatre qui a aidé
ici c'est bon t'es quand même gagnants 1
mais quéméré squale disait je crois h 4
sur les partitions h 4 pour aller à
angers 5 tu vois mais bon il peut faire
encore maintenant elle va faire parce
que tu ne sais pas nue de la fin n'a pas
le droit non kg hg est ambitieux il est
tout le temps mis autant ça qui est
génial donc à bombay auquel tu fais bois
de feu roger cinq crans il prend à 32.5
qu'on s'en fout mais qui tuent aussi
faire g h et jouer pour acheter des
dessins quinze jours est th6 si roger
six bouquets rudd devant vous plus de
fab
ça prend forme la d3 2 3 il en surnom il
a calé en sûr tu dis quoi chaque année
une finale jo joubert
on peut bomber à une pire qu'un vers ces
pays doit se dire oui j'avais entendu à
saint louis que
vlad avait enfin compris ce que c'était
que socoa il gagne le speech est ce rêve
là il est un autre point fort de sault
sais qu'il est croyant il disait en fait
les joueurs d'échecs marrant quand il
perdit son sueur déprimé machin tu as
faim fatou s'en fait pas de carte scène
a great chouquet en passant par par tout
le monde
les élus en fait il est tout le temps
heureux edit c'est une grande force
parce qu'au moins il deviendra pas fou
ou alors il l'est déjà mais pas plus non
mais même si tu es fou mais que tu es
heureux tu vois la fin c'est pas grave à
leur égard mais là c'est pas fou en pls
parano ouais c est cette j'ai pas tout
compris mais bon non mais du coup c'est
bien là tout le temps heureux bien sûr
tu suis tout le temps heureux
bon enfin la tenir un peu moins bien
mais pas énorme ça sont des racailles va
il va forcément répondre non il a
accéléré la cadence une caisse bourse ou
tempo ou encore de ce monde si tu veux
être très énervé super bon je sais pas
cette année quand même enlevé tous
gagner en l'absence de carles scène
jusqu'à la finale et le parcours fait ce
sera facile pendant qu'arles et
d'appariement mais ouais voilà bien
gagner ces matches et même avant
celle-là qu'on imagine qu'il ya des
massacres est bon et puis surtout déjà
perdu deux finales tu vois un mois le
chercher c'est le clermont ferrand du
speech est sacré
un peu plus en plus à l'aise mais je
suis montferrandais ou clermontois tu ne
sais plus un jaune arc
je pense que clermont ferrand ce gagne
plus montferrandais que clermontois nom
de quoi je pense que clermont ferrand
ils sont plus montferrand dès que
clermontois peut-être montferrand c'est
plutôt le club de rugby historique et
comme juste l'argent de michelin et tout
ça ça ouais mais je comprends votre ce
clermont ferrand c'est comme une ville
de l entière et une fusion de 2002 après
[Musique]
on fait rendez en plus et même pas
clermont-ferrand c'est clairement et
montferrand je crois bien oui mais le
panneau ses écrits clermont ferrand truc
oui je sais mais je vais très énervé
quand les firmes en faire on sature et
l'impression de te faire prendre tombe
quand même fait charmant aussi j'en ai
enfin dégage mais je sais pas mais bon
c'est la même chose
mon truc s'appelle
saint-just-saint-rambert je crois qu'il
y avait un côté de
saint-just-saint-rambert que l'autre ont
fusionné quoi est ce que toi tu serais
heureux que les gens appellent bien au
lieu de fabien tu ait enfin je sais pas
fabien biens meubles libye brienon mais
mon père ça fait libye quand alpha
diable clermont ferrand mais qu'est pour
eux quatre dames preuve c'est que des
fourchettes de partout bon les psys ce
fait être ici c'est la solidité
on est là on tient tout et tu m'écoutes
il est solide 320 cela fait il est assez
solide il se voit bien puis 3,7 au sein
d'amd c'est très bien quand la colonne
ouverte donc en mieux attac g4 au
passage et b4
je pense tu payes chekade roubles mais
bon l'hôtel six troupes que ce à quoi tu
es cache quoi ce n'est pas troubles que
je me trompe je
nous trouve que l'on est très clair
qu'en fait c'est chaud quand même pas
mal à quel jeu très vite son b4 machin
comme il joue vite quoi cette partie on
écoute
j'en sais rien je sais pas peut-être
souffert h5 préparer tour des 3 on
voyage 4 après tu vois alors j'ai 5
qu'est ce que c'est
mais si importante que ça car notre dame
c'est simple 1la 5 pour detroit ouais et
puis on se retire kg un pirate bay ou
peut-être on veut faire dame 17 tu vois
et est heureux contourner de l'autre
côté chez ces chocs est pas mal j'ai
cinq en tout cas j'ai cinq pas mal
d'après as acquis son fourgon kg 6
j'imagine dams et 5e faire croire
j'évite de me français 7 4 au match et
ça ça n'est pas laid comme un écart eev
quatre tours d un pour aller menacer des
maths et tout voyez très pragmatique
sous qu'il joue très vite un truc comme
ça je sais pas on va voir dans le
caillage de quelque peu en dehors du jeu
ça trouve il trouve enfin son retour
sans pression que il s'est fait
magouilles et ouais ouais bon c'est pas
foutu
non non il a remonté le temps a passé et
j'ai quatre noms il est beaucoup moins
idiot que ce qui est avant moi mais je
pense qu'ici génial maintenant depuis
quelques 3 4 5 qui arrive autour d un
faux c'est plus à des moments différents
ouais bien jouer n'a qu'a déjà vous ok
adams et six noms n'ont pas d'âme ses 6
il prend une paye à raison de deux
laissé couler la montre donc qu'elle
cinq élèves trois fous ces quatre
italiennes rock des 6 et 3 allez hop et
on y va l'italienne de nouveau la même
variante faut aussi penser est pris à
eux six cavaliers afin b4 machin ok il
sait qu'à toi cette fois ci qu'est dont
il reprend menace éventuellement de
prendre en b 6 mai peut-être plutôt de
commencer par à 4 comme ça il poussera
les noirs à bouger le pion et frac et
mambé 600 kg 4 sf2 peut-être il doit
prendre en b 6
et puis chassé lecavalier après aussi
possible et garde la menace a4 a6 qui
est franc b6 qui détruirait la structure
de pions il se passe quoi la sueur à 4
la casse ça me paraît être bien candidat
comme clou à 6 est requis et bicici
c'est quand même un détruit la structure
ouais alors je vous pose la question une
fois j'ai juste eu cette opportunité
dans une partie j'ai pas pris b6 s'était
passé la position mais j'ai joué avec un
fouet trois voitures
je demande à la fin j'avais un flou
trois ans un tube et si ses chais pas
trop on leur dit m'avait dit oui tu dois
prendre mais je suis pas convaincu je
sais pas où je me pose toujours la
question en tout cas ça a l'air assez
convaincant ce que fait vrai ce n'est
pas mal quand même pas mal du tout il va
s'en fout et écoute tu commences à te
prendre un peu d espace sur cette aile
d'am-dam b3 les tours qui vont jouer
c'est plus wesley so c'est wes les shows
fabien il est chaud et cela allait et
c'est la vérité fabien madame france et
bien sans en enfonçant son footeux
peut-être laissé un cadeau qui faire
gaffe qui foutent
non peut-être l'effet je crois qu'il ya
des histoires kg 4 quoi voit-on jean
maitron chemise d'agît show j'en ai
marre je suis complètement sur café pour
2,3 et prépare peut-être b5 la halle et
b5 maintenant à bien ou mal dans le
money time tomber la chemise coup vous
êtes un petit nul non pas de put jamais
mais c'est la guerre des nerfs qui te
faire [ __ ] en d4 épais mais 17ème et
ça à parier qu'il va arrive en f4 on va
se prendre une attaque violente et
mettre à quai pour h trois échecs direct
je n'aime pas qui je suis a pris 1,5 ici
mais je sais pas il fait juste puis on
prend et un médecin ou un trou no way
mais kf4 donne prend 2,5 et projectiles
prendrait fin au flou le laissera bob
quérir un coup tiré parti pour ça est
très somptueux en france on va peut-être
que damas pour prendre 5 aussi ils
attaquent le machin avec 3 hockey le roi
côte est et jusqu'à devait arriver mais
est-ce que tours 4-1 coup mais qu'il est
on prend un tour à tour j'ai quatre dans
le cas des quatre commun qu'est ce que
cavalia h4 et un coup mais on a abusé
cinq corps gris ces critiques tout ce
qui se passe ici
peut faire quoi faire mon roi jockey f4
j'ai l'impression qu'il est normal torje
1 et pas dommage 5 peut-être un truc
comme ça il ya des trois en prise aux
siens mais y'a des six en contrepartie
bon il est pas trop trop bien mais il
est malin le pokédex 3d requis étrangers
2 mais cette dame à saint vincent qui
avait 6 kg 4 ça va ouais il faudra
prendre des trois au pire un et ont
peut-être dame 17 mai mais d'amener
ceinture à 1,5
on est mal parti trop tactique en fait
faut pas rentrer là dedans je fais la
remarque tout à l'heure une fois et ça
se passe bien pour lui quand c'est trop
tactique comme ça menaka peut-être
meilleur potentiel du monde dans ce type
de position
ouais bon d'autant plus sa version
internet en blitz ou quoi dangereux
tient peut-être j'aurais pris en russie
sur échec avant que pas laisser damer
cinq échecs
je fais faut prendre bessette et puis et
puis espérer n'ont fait que ça que les
prières que marché il est croyant
peut-être le sauver quoique est ce que
tu es si perdant perdant que ça monte
moins bien c'est sûr tu gagneras pas
c'est sur mais bon ton roi est pour le
moins assez bien défendu finalement et
le pion de plus ce pion est bon le
renoir un peu ouvert aussi pour les perd
pas et éventuels tue pas à quel point
c'est perdant perdant
j'ai déjà raté dégaine un truc comme ça
mais poste surtout j'ai bien meilleur
des tubes je pense qu'elle aime bien ce
kanye west avons la dame prend à 6 tours
b un rouage 2 il y aura dame cinq échecs
alors là c'est bon mais non non vraiment
ça se gagne bien qu'on en fait je pense
il s'est pris la petite combine tactique
qui a fait mal quoi bon après tu me
diras y aura toujours une combine
tactique qui fait mal bon faut arriver
il va réaliser de fer tour c'est un tour
ce tableau 5
ok y'a pas terme est séparé de cette
montée tranquille juste à la main est
mal placé mais bon il va réussir à la
faire de pas faire arrive a ajouté le
roi par ci par là
ce cachet rock cinq dames des 3 5g pavin
et s'y lie à perpète un problème mais
bon le juge mal mon visage non non il
n'ya pas perpètrent mais bon si on
devait un peu et roy et cette fois la
plus jeune ministre douteuses 8,8
on pensait que ouais ça avait fait le
break vite des briques non mais s'est
fait débreaker présente on reste à
égalité
bon ben on a cac consolide suivante un
peu plus de 102 viennoise mme ce que x 3
tu prends de l'adami sinon plus toi je
sais pas peut-être à ce que je fais
c'est quatre d'entre eux qu'avec les
blancs et du coup je fais dame 17 way
et dans le genre ffu aussi c'est jean
ray lane avant d'aller vite plus haut à
droite juste f6 3,7 du peu le grand
crash aurait pas pris le risque mais bon
bah ça toi s'il s'impose à tous qu'en
dix neuf
oui pour moi j'aurais joué sa meilleure
part la fondamentale mange aurais pas
pensé que c'était bon bon on va pas
l'air trop mal juste comme ça
ok ou 4 bien bon choix
c'est une honte pour les noir sans
opposition faire gaffe avec ses grandes
parfois tu te prends des attaques genre
tout d'un coup tu as dû tout reprendre
et cette dame à 4 fin d'article à la
brigade du tampon 17 tours bien qui fait
mal ou genre de truc fulgurant wef est
hyper méfiant parce que mine de rien le
pion b il peut être difficile à défendre
gratuitement des six cantons font bon
après ça que je dis dans le style des
joueurs c'est plus de poteaux promoteurs
ça va juste très bien pour les mares
mais déjà il est là même troqué en
dessin est greffé des trucs déjà il a
usé de sa position en l'espace de 2-3
cool cafistes ses qualités fondamentales
du strict
je la sens pas du tout pour nager sans
mon jeu mais bien d'un moment mais là je
sens que c'est son style d'opposition
juste en fait mais ça m'est déjà bien
arrivé de me faire défoncer comme ça
avec les noirs genre tu penses que tout
va bien et genre 3,4 quoi apprêtez-vous
à doit plus faites vos jeux
c'est bizarre en fait se tranche des
vitres
cette fois c'est sûr il a raison de se
mettre là bas fait l'idéal serait pour
le ramener en bessette mais ça a l'air
dur qui devra faire pousser 8 quoi mais
bon
bon ça re va pas trop mal en cas de shu
en base ça va ça va plus on sait plus
quoi dire quoi ça a clairement non c'est
bien ce qu'on attaque des trois pays la
jay 5 rue servient chance sur trois les
cinq bons et que beaucoup de salariés
dans ces six pièces mal
il faut faire prendre 5 1 pour les
banques en crise prises n'ya peut-être
d'amd 4 à la fin et attaque tout en fait
peut-être que tous les côtés les risques
on peut prendre des trois ici bas
bientôt crise il faudra peut-être
prendre de 5 mais ça va en fait ce que
tu as gagné détroit et peut-être même
ccaf en fait du coup là pour croiser le
fer en béton ouais non et ça marche pas
en fait concerner notre zizou a plus ou
moins joué cavalier e de ici et on prend
des trois mais on prend des trois éclats
d'âme et ses 4 ok tu peux faire c'est
cinq jours accueille ses cadres il prend
comme ça quand même
qu'est-ce qu'il faut venu pour toi ok on
pense à la whey mais bon on va prendre
deux trois
ouais ok refresh 6 des bonbons ce
changement je pense que voir avec quoi
il prend 5,6 vous sûr d'apprendre tête
ils échangent des dames hier mais la
tour en d6 et l'envoie c'est je pense à
la finale deux tours gagne facilement la
tête tu fais pour des 6 et surtout
reprend 1,5 à tour c'est assez bien base
non mais ça s'est super bien joué de la
part de chaque cas est ce que c'est bien
joué et fab ce que tour66 du coup
surprise tu prends du roi et à dammaj
six échecs et adam prend 1,5 million
with finul est sûrement un peu mieux
avec les noirs encore j mais ok pas si
nulle en mai de faire deux défaites
d'affilée
je stoppe l'hémorragie non non mais t'es
pions sont plus avancés donc dans les
finales de damas avancé des pions c'est
hyper important
dans le plus bref c'est pas mal tu pas
pour le blanc c'est toujours un petit
contre ogeu way qui a l'air de suffire à
bomber 500 is peut-être sur a pu
attendre efsa trois femmes ces quatre
jeunes en référé mais ce courage et six
chez bosch pour cette sphère du tout moi
je ne sais pas qui est mieux là je
comprends que l'argent bon j'ai tout
fait que des échecs
la dame centrale comme c'est bien c'est
quand même vraiment pas je pense qu'il a
merdé jusqu'aux îles car à proposer
mieux la bretagne reste 20 minutes
rester grand chose il reste 17 minutes
donc ça va toute façon ça va aller en
bullet avec un petit écart ça va pas ça
passe a pas tourné avec un gros écart
bon au moins une finale on a un match
voilà on a un vrai match là on a un vrai
match mais bon ça que ça a un côté
tellement fatigué donc des partis tout
le temps tout en doutant moins je sais
vraiment qui est le meilleur mais c'est
juste cette admirable nous est dans le
fantasme
là je sens que j'en maman je vais a plus
rien je commencerai faire que des
conneries sur conneries mais ils sont
forts c'est pour ça que j'ai le truc du
mental et où quand ils vous pendant
longtemps tu vois qu'ils en ont je pense
juste que le format cantat que deux
trois parties tu arrives tu arrives à
froid etc peuvent non mais ce n'est pas
du tout mon temps à faire des conneries
parce que je ne trouverais un mois je
vois rien parce que je serai fatigué je
rêve ça va tu es trop d'efforts avant où
j'en sais rien encore jean singer pape
reste cadence mais je sens que le fait
de ne jamais soufflé fait justement tu
as forcément un coup de mou quoi
d'ailleurs sol a eu lie ces deux buts
d'affilée ou quoi il faudrait
apparemment une mine entre deux parties
devaient voir un verre d'eau fait un
truc souffle et quant à mes exercices
qui fait le charme au final le fait que
ça s'enchaîne ça fait aussi le charme du
truc c'est que fenêtres soufflées
on va peut-être faire g5 qui ont encore
une fois en un pion tient pas trop le
choix
allez prends ça j'ai gardé les fours
mais vers des 3,6 et du h 4 h 50 on a
très faim direct j'aime bien puisque tut
tut bloque un peu la tour eiffe sais tu
cru un peu le cavalier des cinq tuvache
4h 5h je pense directement fait alors
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le chatt
peut-être faire b3 ici mais b3 b5 assez
chaud
bon je sois dans chose en chef c'est le
rêve de beaucoup de monde le chat tu
peux - malheureusement dû suivre
malheureusement je prépare un peu comme
sap
ok ok bon écoute j'aime bien les blancs
je pense qu'aussi mais un eiffel qui
distingue très fort bien sûr bluetooth
et 4 donc à un moment pour le tourner je
pense par ado b1 ou un truc comme ça non
je pense d'affaires fois de un moment
donné est pas sûr qu'ils fassent faut
bien les j'ajuste x 2 je veux faire qu
avec d'injustice ils veulent mettre en
d3 c'est bien joué ça peut-être même à
80 nous ait changé d'âme quand ils ont
son roi et plus en danger que le nôtre
donc pour qu'elles échangent donne le
ton
c'est beau mais bon du coup ils troquent
à 4 contre des quatre mais il a réussi à
aillas le fuji 5 qui reste en prison ces
braquages mais vend fois sur ont perdu
en cueille boujou dommages sis ou je ne
sais quoi
5e et cavaliers bouge h4 ou cavaliers h4
en échange tous ont fait dames c'est ce
à quoi eric à la finale et perdu deux
façons
1 la jeune en perte de vitesse très
pauvre expérience dans une sorte de
fatigue ce dont on parle avant juste
traces de faim je pense tu dors et bras
droit un petit temps mort en fait ils
demanderont tu le sens un parent joueurs
par match mais temps mort ces jarres
trois minutes ou deux minutes je sais
pas mais peut-être lieu des pauses en
fait des temps morts pour les prendre
quand tu veux tout de temps mort inquiet
mais là il va récupérer ses 6 quand même
c'est pas on sait pas il sait pas ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'est h4 qui paraissait
trop fort ce que t'a proposé juste avant
je pense était très fort mais las il
tord huit dames france et 6 ok mais tour
eiffe certes mesdames francis quand même
niveau pion au niveau pions quête après
cet échec c'est très bien joué à voir
est proposée proches des victimes
c'est comme saddam français si ce niveau
peut enfin tu vas en avoir 3 quand même
des quotas des soutiens on espère aller
l'attaquant sera important du match
parce que trop dernière faut qu'ils
tiennent jusqu'à la pause en fait on le
sent en difficulté faudra les vagues
étaient hautes à au machin chrome n'a
comme métro pie ix et futurs réguler le
nombre de partis en fait plus tu
augmente les possibilités de la variance
va prendre là nul c'est peut-être même
c'est peut-être même nakao finale qui
est en danger dans cette finale puisque
l'échangé dame doit donner une position
gagnante mais si vous me rendais sacré
bon on s'en sort bien et qui le key west
heures les photos d'hier seulement qu il
reste douze minutes donc qui reste deux
ou trois parties maximum alors une
petite petite cape town and en règle
avait perdu une ridicule sokona coeur
d'un des états unis soit cette année
soit ya deux ans j'ai cru qu elle ne
ferait pas jusqu'au bout là où il a fait
une qualité
mais cette année je sais plus mais on va
donner c'est censé être juste il est
heureux qu'il ait doublé un coin moment
mais je sais plus qui va tenir
ce serait bien qu'ils tournent à plus 1
mais ça paraît même genre ont
l'impression que c'est un peu comme le
match contre mvl bon sauf que maxi avait
craqué plutôt entre guillemets j'ai
l'impression que naka et il a pris le
dessus mais pas vraiment au niveau du
jeu c'est plus qu'il peut commencer par
des lâchers sosa
ouais c'est plus la répétition de
l'effort qu'ils sont plus simples pour
pour hikaru que pour os les mais
sûrement dû à un talent intrinsèque dans
les tactiques plus important et donc à
fort soit tu fatigues et lui il allait
les réflecteurs et flex ouais je pense
pas que lui il se fait trois grammes de
speed chose ils enchaînent à faire des
puzzles des machins et un stream quoi en
fait oui oui et puis là-bas tu en as un
grand maître chinois on sait pas qui
c'était méchant écrivait que c'était soi
ou angao soit bout pour il a défoncé un
mauvais coach lensois c'est pas mauvais
à l'un ou l'autre mais je pensais plutôt
que vers sommet mais bon qui s'est fait
défoncer une s'atteler de baboo que
j'avais lune et carlson la tenue d'une
toile et ça lui a pas fait peur un tabou
il n'ya pas sourcillé quoi x 6 j'imagine
bon je pensais qu'ils allaient faire ses
droits inclus en 2001 en matière
d'options plus là et ce n'est jamais bon
c'est de plus un peu chelou
il est à deux pas le temps de faire qui
est décrite comme tour des cinq qui est
peut-être possible en x 3 ou qu'ils
aient à faire bouger cette dame
c'est un peu chiant bref cinq noms du
parti si c'est pour ça que je vais
[ __ ] la tour en dessins on est comme
angers les deux pions normaux après
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais franchement on verra
si cette fête tour v8 acquis des tours
prend d un trouver un tu as tu feras tu
es chanceux c'est tour je ne veux plus
rien voir
ouais et après tu échanges sur le fait
d'un première ou surfer fou bessette
côté gages
je sais tout est changé je m'appelle
ouest gso tutu appelaient sur
l'échiquier alors il a le chat en plus
en photo donc bon de faire le chat à
tout moment quoi il ya son chant photo
william yockey c'est pour ça que je
misais le ps et ce chaque l'arrêt bien
sûr et je suis mais ce chat qui était
son nom au chat je sais pas si tu pars
ce chat qui es-tu tempêtant bien voilà
où kevin bail mais bon enfin moi je fais
tout est changé je suis très heureux
comme un fou on sent son niveau quand
même bas mais ça va là bas c est ce que
ce que fout c'est un peu une question
que je tenais mais je vais table c'est
cet échec pourrait vouloir tenir je vais
me tourner ni pas plus qu'autre chose
les férois f2p prévention ok mais tu
veux faire peut-être dame prend à te
tais dame p3 à ces questions ce que je
reporte pas mal pour le parrainage truc
ça y est toujours dans le jeu et passent
et plus on est bon le cahier 6 pour
l'instant il y bien entre le mat on
avait plus besoin de maths du tout on a
quand même de plus en plus en finale ok
mais les fous bombe à défaut swim kiev
et sfr fou ce harper s'est vite et
recyclables
patrick chaboudez 4 en fait sinon ce que
fout des quatre fonds prend à 7 le pion
à passer sa meuf tel prix ont baissé ça
va mais oui non le foot j'aime bien au
moins un truc pareil je veux gagner
c'est en gros ce rebond d'hier je me
suis où je ne rebondit du parfum
je retourne en des 8 nov
je reviens à l'écurie peut-être qu'ils
aient des sentiers vite ou que tu vas
passer par b6 et et je sais pas prêt
mais il attaque le pion b3 enfin il veut
faire pousser car ce n'est peut-être
plus beaux matchs joués c'est encore
méthode à 6 ouais merci je pense y
prendrait cette taille critique ont des
cinq room avec un des huit allées bien
vient de près mais il ya eu 5 faire f 6
et 4 soirs il s'en fout il aux dires des
structures j'aime pas succomber cinq
mois une montée à la whey mais est ce
que c'est si grave est ce que les blancs
est ce que tu peux pas aller faire un
gros jeu à l'e3 avec 3 ok bon look et la
d766 bon ça donne juste un petit il
n'empêche c'est hyper changerait fait
rage sortent du tribal ou g5 g5
peut-être faire j'ai quatre mois tous
les pions sur noir il ya bien sûr et du
coup je suis 5
la chanteuse r'n'b droit et j'ai six
mois il fait juste un bon cavalier nos
pires méthodes il a décidé de juste
attendre et faire des alertes rouges
cavaliers pragmatique et qui demandent
son adversaire de chercher bien mais
apprend avait pas y avoir de garantie on
va faire des allers-retours nuls ont élu
ça aujourd'hui
peut-être qu'il faudrait faire mais je
me demande quand même s'il aurait même
s'il pouvait pas partir avec son wright
du roi gsis les scellés blanc rasé les
pions halal dams que c'était quand même
l'ont élu à attaquer de l'autre côté
donc encore l'italien non utilisés femme
je demande quand même s'il était tué il
y aurait quand même pu partir comme un
fou allait droit laissé les blancs faire
ce que tu as fait qu'il fasse froid c63
17,3 prend à eux huit trois décès 3
français 3 b 7 3 prend assad tu vois
c'est parce qu'il avait un temps de
faire bref c'est 3g wife cinq projets
qu'à 3h 3 vous bouffez pousser son pion
h quoi bon il a joué la sécurité parce
que ça paraissait un peu long quand même
pour le roi de tout allait raser non dur
à dire j'avais après ce faux trop
calculer ou moins s'il a fait ce qu'il
sait sur quoi faire nous mêmes parce que
pour gagner il ne faut pas prendre des
risques face à un tel joueur
ouais mais là le truc fin fait j'ai pas
qu'on dira mais vu la physionomie du
match ce week end à un parti maken perdu
2 je te dis ok fait ton temps faibles
mais que faut limiter la casse dans le
temps faibles ou après l'absolu je suis
d'accord enfin très chaud oui
normalement le bullet va pas le
favoriser et que ton prendre des points
qui peuvent enfin mais c'est juste que
visuellement j'ai l'impression que tu
vas plus vite parce que quoi tu fais roi
prend h 3 h de et tu pousses le monde la
direction en bessin mais bon il est
quand même envie de te fait roi c63 17,3
prend 1,88 à prix repartir de l'autre
côté bon prégent ans c'est rien c'est
plus facile constamment le conte la
revoir j'admets marché nous est
exactement les pièces montrent qu'à
position bordélique bonne foi après ce
coup des 5 vient de partout ça a joué à
fond ensemble ça a tout changé
bon ok ça va
c'est 3 je pense à peut-être ou quoi ces
trois noms retenus cahier cinq arrivées
juste résultat d'un dur à dire je sais
pas et à la mc2 aussi en est d'ailleurs
si je sais pas pourquoi on aime c'est un
bon gars et des cinq quand même est-ce
que juste baissé c'est pas possible
c'est trop haute pour des 8 tu prendras
de troyes et à tours dont une puce bon
il ya la part de fou toujours mais bon
les cahiers sont pas si mal un petit 4
min 6 quand même ça va vite
la sema moins bien avec les blancs non
je pense pas après bon tu vois pas bon
mais sur les foules bulls écrit mais
j'ai pas je sens guy cavaliers ils sont
là il reste 2 minutes 40 dans la cadence
je pense pas fable que cette partie dure
moins de 2 minutes 40
donc ce sens c'est notre dernière partie
du 3.5
ok ce serait bien pour le stade de
gagner cette partie du coût pour avoir
un petit petit pécule avant le non l'a
peut-être 4 quand même de me poncet
quatre tours c'est 39.4 princesse est
sûre je ne fais pas échanger ses quatre
effets retour ces trois bêtement
ailleurs à b5 mais je suis peut-être
cavaliers des machins jeux peuvent
sembler trop c'est trop tard c'est cette
moi même mais je suis loin de tout ça
dès maintenant sur pied du raf prend 1,5
j'aimerais que tu fais ton truc ouais
mais là dessus on fait quoi il fait à 4
cette remarque a tu bouges le fou juste
il est une bombe est d'accord mais
bessin qui va peut-être le cas yeux des
deux ponts avec le sacre en d2 bref un
moment un peu moins long à obtenir sa
maîtrise d'eux doit rentrer dedans
il a peut-être une autre idée à temps et
qui a vu des dauphins c'est ce truc que
j'ai vu mais bon enfin que tu as dans
re5 on imagine à tarnac at il fait des
grimaces de vasco est peut-être il veut
faire un à quatre aussi certains font
des deux mois je pensais après un an au
codir dans celle là il va jouer à
retenir actuel maire de toi que tu - ce
qui s'est vraiment être là de jeux
achetés à traves en cg je vais me
reprendre alentours bon c'est pas grave
mais bon c'est chiant à tenir ces
finales à chaque fois où on ans du
stream ne pratique pas si la paire nil
ou pas je crois que c'est une
amélioration peut-être conduire noir
soit comme ça cairo - shanghai sont
rangées de pour pas laisser de
possibilité même de ravir les béliers
sûrement mieux en g2 pour acheter des
bonbons pour l'instant il fait un truc
normal le problème des noirs c'est que
s'ils veulent progresser de faire
relever donc je leur tour et soit sûr
que les échecs bien bon à rien nous
t'aimons tu fais échec latéraux de
nouveaux bons ressens je concilie compte
juste de quoi manger puis ça va il ya
huit ans et 50 secondes
égalité fantastique 1 est-ce que ce les
machins là c'est la pause
ok bon show organisé il ya eu égalité
dans les deux cas dans sa pour le moment
cinq partout en 5 + 1 5 partout en trois
puissants ok bon sympa sympa en tout cas
suspens on est content emporte ses
finissants même d'apporter aussi de
saison 2 le speech est quoi voilà c'est
vraiment l'apothéose apothéose ça va se
jouer à rien ménaka quand même favori un
bullet on va voir ce que ça donne quand
même énormément ce sont c'est son truc
c'est sa cadence ce fétiche mais ouais
ce qu'on dit après je sais pas j'ai
d'être soit un plus ainsi un peu
différente bien plus 0 qui est sa vraie
vraie spécialité alors infuser rona
science que serait aucune chance en 1 +
1 will a peu de chance mais bon il
sépare aide moi je pense l'époque je
pensais pas que tu as vraiment non non
moi j'ai pensé qu'il y aurait au moins
plus 3 + 4 à ce moment là du match au
moins donc déjà déjà super match bravo
et il faut converger de chant petit
verdot quasi aveugle de suite ça va
envoyer les mecs sains saran le moment
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit un petit
partage
si vous si vous le souhaitez pas ce que
ça va être le
le gros moments vous mettre un petit
bien si vous voulez partager ça va
vraiment être le gros gros gros gros au
moment du match les bullet et le spi
thiès qui va vraiment se décider dans
les derniers instants donc ça c'est
sympa quand je peux être un jeu mettre
un petit lien si vous souhaitez partager
alors sait où c'est ici il faut le temps
que ça arrive avec un peu en pls pour
pourrait rapidement des pages quand tout
est ouvert comme ça on leur dit qu'ils
aient vraiment ps alors on va y arriver
wen à 44/100 c'était un globule est trop
facile pour pour karl scène bien si vous
souhaitez partager il va arriver et en
fait la finale va redémarrer au même
moment
alors maintenant bull est là trente
minutes ça fait une dizaine de partis en
gros ça va faire dix parties en bullet
le prédit parti assure henri méjean
toutes les cadences en fait ça fait à
peu près 10 parties oui ces soirées sont
invalidés well truc de m ouais ça va
être dur pour essayer quand même hein
mais il ya pas mal on était encore non
plus donc
et qu'est-ce que tu regrettes qui pue
les 960
non je regretterai pas ce que ça rendait
le match un peu incompréhensible
pourquoi partie 960 avant de commencer
le pas comme je le disais en fait
j'espère comme il s'est souvent de faire
des formats compréhensible pour le plus
grand nombre et le 960 le problème c'est
que pour le grand public ça reste
bizarre comme personne ne comprenait
rien donc je pense que c'est pour du
mieux qu'ils l'ont qui l'ont enlevée et
en plus les matches étaient un poil long
parce qu'elle comptait pas dans les 90
minutes en fait donc savez les matchs de
faire des matchs de 3h15 à des matchs de
3h45 déjà là je trouve que c'est un poil
long je pense que faire une heure quinze
ouais ouais je pense vont enlever cinq
dix minutes à toutes les cadences mais
bon ils veulent un truc cadres et facile
à retenir donc beaucoup pourquoi c'est
pas mal
m'étonne c'est que je ne pourrai fondu 3
plus haut du 3 + 2 bah je sais pas alors
abrite trois plus simple j'ai fait une
bêtise en mettant le remettant ce
partage est perdue le chronomètre mais
je le retrouvais lire dans les faits
même chose ouais ouais c'est pas évident
de tout avoir sur l'écran ce que j'en ai
une quantité industrielle de fenêtres et
l'ordinateur qui ouvre pas les trucs
rapidement mais ça va aller je sais je
sais où le retrouver ce que j'ai déjà
fait dire arrière mais il voit demande
le système de ca dre mais en fait ce
qu'on me disait c'est que caisse comme
des rats partons avec twitter pour la
diffusion de ce trou mais tition et
twitch en fait ils te prennent le
partenariat si tu tiens certain temps à
l'antenne
donc ils ont dû vendre un truc doit
acheter un truc chez soi quand ça marche
qui fait quoi on se met d'accord en tout
cas pour trois heures et demie de jeu et
ses 3000 jeu ou 3h15 ou trois heures
afin de jeter par mu steiner minutes à
une heure de mai donc pour eux ce qui
est plus intéressant d'avoir un format
comme ça même si pour l'intérêt sportif
avec le truc du 7 serait plus sympa mais
du coin là pour la pleine 30 matches ça
changerait pas grand chose voilà pour
cela non mais évite non mais ça se fait
ça servira juste à éviter les matchs où
il ya un trop gros massacre
oui oui clairement brassée par thierry
dernière demi heure
le bullet et ça va se jouer à rien
fabing pas et même si nadal gagne la
finale ce sera joué à rien là de toute
façon partie comme ça ça se joue tout en
bullet en 1 + 1 tout peut arriver mais
on voit hanak a déjà qui met la pression
directement à la pendule un le trajet
des actifs une heure je veux dire oui je
suis l'un et du coup ça il est fort il
est fort ce dakar leur
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'il le met
directement sous pression dès les
premiers coups je sais pas comment il
fait ok ça va qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc il à pioncer tease bonjour dans la
partie coeur j'ai raté le début c'est
peut-être ça va ce qui va devoir prendre
des trois prix des trois rois eux deux
cette fois 6
ouais il vous faut à 6 sur camaïeu 5 il
fait pas tourner rond puis à la fois que
ce tour soit fougue et 4g quatre chèques
bien joué je pense voici son prix d'ici
5 ou 4 5 kg à faire crisser 4 pouces et
cette équipe car elle sur le cavalier
tout en bloquant le pion à ce pays dans
la de donner un niveau tant on sent
visée robinson france 4 vous prend c'est
cette france des trois tu gagnes abidjan
mais c'est chaud je rencontre que subway
bien singulière jouer à des jeux c'est
comme une tête de contrat sont
poursuivies tout au tout cavalia 5 est
petit et on prendra 2 prendre un truc
quelle chance et bien jouer et de faire
échec pendant qu'il peut pas vraiment
venir en 3 que deux tours deux échecs
piagge 5
ok là on va pas du tout reprend g2 est
toujours regarder non je crois pas ça
marche pas non et six mois s'apparente
attaques de partout mais jacoutot fait
bon jovi vous prendre la chance de
donner trois mois après et a quand même
deux pions pour la piètre ouais même à
deux on n'attrape pas grand chose je
crois mais bon ok allez revin tanger un
jeu contre 6 juin puisque texte si
ceux-ci guîtres mm et on s'est peut-être
mais il y as qui traînerait bout
g6 imerys courbe moquait il a repris ses
droits non mais bon ces deux tours sénat
on rit pion à des choses le roi va
revenir notamment sa série 5 aussi c'est
justement pour empêcher vous de revenir
mais bon voilà je mets mon père brazon
ça
à pas mal il ya eu 5 qui très bien dans
notre allait se passer encore non c'est
pas faux mais bon déjà papa position
publiques comme avant c'est déjà quelque
chose
j'ai senti bien joué et je suis quasi
sûr tout est nul non mais ça c'est sûr
que c'est dû mais bon c'est du bullet
quoi oui mais souvent il joue plus vite
que les vannes pour un autre et c'est le
truc le plus pénible ambühl est en fait
ce truc là quand tu va défendre ce genre
de final c'est affreux j'ai quoi
d'engins ouais quand j'ai deux échecs et
chacun h latron mais attends truc c'est
qu'il ya tellement peu de temps ni bon
alors on aimait d'un kfc le faire tomber
michel est en tout cas de seconds rôles
4,4 à non il a proposé une huile a pas
eu le temps d'accepter au mais c'était
vraiment nul ça bagis 4.460 âgées 3 à
tampa me pose c'est pas nul
moi j'ai trois cinq sept et perdant mais
n'a qu'a proposé nul dans une position
voyais pas ce que c'est vraiment dégueu
les trois fois d'imposition probablement
plus
l'armée c'est horrible non mes
[Musique]
compositions 2006 pour le flaguais way
qui est juste doit abandonner là sans
jouer non mais je pense que je pense
juste que pour le truc fair play quand
tu proposes nul même si le mec tombe de
voir deux trois secondes 2 tu vois de
répit où ils peuvent un coup ça doit
faire nul automatique en fait sa propre
aux élus le mec ton de l'annuler fait
quoi enfin c'est quoi la règle anciens
arbitres dans deux lettres en partie
l'antre pour deux nuls et l'acceptent
tombe on va dire non mais je suis curé
la non mais d'accord mais c'est du
niveau dur de dire à un moment le maître
les pactes juge bien alors il aurait pu
proposer nul sur son temps s'ils avaient
vraiment voulu faire nul il proposait
une sur son temps qu'elle a joué la
proposer ni ça me sauve en sueur il a
pas réussi à accepter mais en plus ils
étaient gagnés en à camille s'en est pas
rendu compte
ou alors juste qu'il a fait savoir
trouver les 5e et y attendiez bâtir ce
bouton d'euros quelque part et qui
trouve pas jean louis c'est un problème
du site mairie par nom sera programmée
du site caf s'est saoulé site pareil sur
oppose nice et accepte pas tu tombes tu
ton quoi mais
bon on espère un coup la connaissent
leur hockey ils disent que moi je voyais
pas la caméra mais ils disent qu'ils
étaient surpris d'avoir gagné quand
quand le truc ça arrêtez donc il n'a pas
à mon avis la juge lui proposait nul
proprement quoi je sais pas c'était
surtout que pourquoi proposer du halal
or si ces gagnants que y'a pas compris
qu'ils étaient gagnants mais vous allez
peut-être tour 17 ou 50 plus non mais
ces choix il y avait 2 ans prise quand
même que deux amis à la fois à sept îles
se réveille damas un couple steve jobs
serait peut-être fou b8 non de la faire
rager à leur tour et quelle branche 3 3
qu'est ce que c'est que ça quelques
épreuves je crois vraiment ça va prendre
trois secondes
qu'est ce qu'on va faire tour 3 l'a fait
le tomber quoi il est synchro tiéné 5
il pousse tout quoi marois leucate et tu
pousses caisse pas si simple à gagner
prend une touche des femmes ou s'être
réunis n'ont plus gagné ça se gagne pas
dans quel but comme ça
est ce que c'était vraiment gagnant
entre gaye et peut-être une chance je
pense qu'on pouvait mieux la jouer
beaucoup c'est par un bon voisin il pas
ridicule lors d'une des deux parties de
des bullet time il ya pas ridicule mais
je pense qu'il va perdre de justesse
quand elle est simple et curan bon ben
si ça t'a mais je ne comprends pas le
point incluent ceux des six que je
réclame à chaque partie voilà enfin six
essais personne ne veut faire
tiens voilà suis tu te rends fou un
phare un fou moi arrêtons ces sites on
s'en fout
100 votants pensent et sara lee
je suis très énervé là je réservais de
la première partie encore c'est dur quoi
michael prend également sa une sur
quatre les joues quoi d'autre flag et
évite les flammes et ont tué cinq tomes
avec les marins presse que c'est ce que
tu fais qu'un rus/kat échec
oui tu fais sonne toi même pas ce que
quelqu'un peut pas les en a eu deux tu
vas faire tout reprend accueilli ces
trois et paypal en f3 je veux aller en
juin
d'autres tags et autres encore ouais tu
vas gagner un pion un badge et 207 un
cadeau aussi je pense du projet de plu
toribio dégage mais il joue mieux on dû
l'être c'est génial yorkaise de 4 bon
bassiste et puis on fait nullement corps
et mon but mais tu vois un peu ça quand
même un doute le jour de gauche paul
flag et n'arrivera pas un plat gable ah
ok c'est le plan pour aller prendre ça
mais ça va pas suffire
la conseiller sur le roi
inquiet faut aller bosser
ça c'est bien joué ça n'est-ce comme tu
vas t'en serai gré surprend ok il va
nous devrons à 4 à 5
il va peut-être faire à cinq ans je
pensais que c'était pas si grave de
nombreux cours avec le roi vers des deux
peut être devant
ouais mais tu peux pas rentrer là bas il
attend 30 qu'il va ouais ben ali montre
pas grand chose mais c'est juste passé
chat ça va pas suffire
il est fornaka quand même un à bientôt
de nestlé a bien défendu la partie
d'avant ce dommage de pas organique 1 6
3 comme puce tegra 3 contre tout ça
ouais c'est gros là dans celle là il
prend la décision raisonnable vite de
jeu les flous reposer après et là comme
la défendre
tous les thèmes les machins ne tarissant
en suisse il a très bien passé mais
c'est pas pour rien que j'ai un pied fou
quoi c'est pas pour rien que le soleil
c'est la seule personne qu'il est battu
c'est manu ça ça veut quand même dire
beaucoup
hier des quatre menaces que tu as
peut-être tombé de bizarre comme ça je
sais pas je préfère les noirs maintenant
bon long terme c'est bien que les blancs
en fait ça a l'air tellement dur à jouer
dans ces 2 h 4 va tu peux tu peux faire
des choses une prime des ratés solide
bateaux très solide
mais bon froid constructif à un moment
qui est en train de faire
qui fait planter tu prends et tu vas
perdre un pion et se revendent 6 mais
bon sept tours à huit tours à deux tours
à 6 bon ok il fait pas 2 c
ok pour faire d'un prêt de six mois le
site je vois pour rambo coin pour
comprendre peut-être des photos siens
allaient mal
bon pour sortir 6 kg enfin il faut
peut-être au premier set la trop lent en
fait je vais avoir un truc surtout
enlever certains et de temps points 4 en
guinée ces systèmes dans le vin white ra
sur sa marche pas
ban et je crois que c'était seul coup
non oui enfin autant abandonner non mais
justement il craque deux points d'écart
il reste combien de caen shebab 14h09
bas et c'est du rhin a en ce sens qu'il
est pas loin mais nak ahern tout petit
bijou plus vite je plus vite ils peuvent
pas retourner opportuniste bien plaisant
toi ton plus l'organisateur corps mais
la finale de tout à l'heure aussi y en a
une que d'un cas de gagner une queue ou
assez gagne pas quoi ça la fout de
couleurs opposées et l'autre finale deux
tours c'est à peu près la même chose
il est un chouia plus rapide à la voile
fabrice ici il va très très vite en
attaque la haye il est hyper fort megan
apurement ouais y'a peut-être tout
reprend des uns et le pur 4 s'il traîne
à la fin même jean iii comme dedans
quand tu es bon tu peux aussi faire qui
a balayé calcul c'est clair physique et
moi non je n'ai pas vu la caméra meris
cette variante la russie possible non
c'était que cinq attaques dès cet été
deux grues comme square garden ok tout
restera peut-être bien joué et a détruit
la structure étape à tour henri troyat
fut ainsi ce fantastique naka away il a
passé un petit tu veux prendre mes trois
ans et anton cette finale et tu va la
perdre
trois nouveaux pions hongrois mauvais
non nova il a planté son âge il est
insupportable
mais ce n'est qu'une fois à quoi bon
écoute il se bat ce sont en tout cas
dire que peut-être même des chances de
nu dans celle là entre la pendule et où
on s'arrête
moi je crois et on vient du coup oui
[Musique]
mais elle prend au caire alors ça va
aller je pense je m'en sors un truc
comme tour b4 maintenant il faut la
tenue et personne ne sait de plus
importants que ce nous notifie ni même
l'état par temps de rage trois tentes et
john on le connaît maintenant et surtout
qui va jouer la pendule a fait une
première bonne foi ont dit non mais je
voulais dire qu'il va laisser tourner la
pendule cette façon en pire et autres
tranches de 2
wesley
ouais c'est qui est quasiment au niveau
faible mais qui ne l'est pas
malheureusement on est crédible et ce
par tous trois juifs cg50 en france
cette tranche 2 kw à bata plus a en fait
avec ces noms là tu es mal à te planter
le geste qui empruntent cette voie hier
encore comme une arrivée à ceux des
patrouilles se pose non mais c'est ça il
est juste un poil plus fort vous
continuez là il va faire du fou j'ai
cinq mamans joueuses opportuniste que le
plus réaliste ouais ils se trompent à un
peu moins quand ils résistent ils
tentent 82,3 arnaque
il est un peu plus fort un bandeau
schlechter de l'asti slave
je crois que c'est victoire obligatoire
pour wesley passe quasi minutes et n'a
qu'à de toute façon c'est qui va jouer
la pendule à fond si si il al'avantage
donc si tu le laisse tourner une finale
rouaf l'option contre roy pourra seul il
va te la jouer pendant trois minutes un
va te faire les 50 coups de partout de
partout donc il va te la faire ouais
avec la seconde partout où il va te la
faire jouer 3 4 minutes donc tu t'es
obligé du m 3 0 l'a si tu l'as eu une
occasion de traîner nul c'est fini on se
regarde parti pour gagner sa mort bon on
a un peu moins mais un pion de plus un
nom mais soit les blancs par an je
préviens je sonne
oui donc du caucase c'est gagnable voilà
une bien jouer autour des 8 avant de
prendre cinq américains comptent leurs
kft sfar wife deux tours c'est 2 et
envoyé après mes deux potes retour des
deux hommes est un investissement à
faire pousser cette fille est tombée en
bas tu réussis à y aller à savoir pas
mignon il va faire flamber 4 x 5
une sorte de bloquer solution je me sens
trahi non programmés sont c'est nul ça
m'est égal d'être absolument ravis il
est fort et ça lève à tarbes et c'est
exactement le cas de figure bon qu'est
d'interrogation de veiller session phase
5b 6b ce faire trois à cinq ans fait
avoir bien joué
il associe une problème très vite enfin
il est vraiment très fort
et ça va durer pendant des heures c'est
exactement le cas de figure c'est
exactement le cas de figure il va te
jouer à 50 coups ou alors ce que c'est
un autre joueur américain il va pas osé
mais ça m'étonnerait
connaissant le bonhomme sur la ba ba
écoute cissé il traîne encore longtemps
en trois parties il y aura pas le cas et
c'est ce qu'ils proposent nul évidemment
il fait un peu de 6 mai cinéma la caméra
jean-louis je réfléchis comment est ce
que je peux gagner quoi après s'il veut
faire salle salle il peut très bien que
j'ai quatre radars est one il a
peut-être compter qu'on y avait deux
coups en fait tant qu'ils ses grimaces
pour juger gardons bon moment
un live
à y réfléchir encore c'est génial six
minutes 25 rames et voilà six ans que
j'en parlais juste avant la partie solo
il est écoeuré il est mort de rire ça le
fait marrer c'est soit il est mort de
rire
il a un fou rire quoi il peut encore
prendre le fou en fait et refaire le
truc pas que ce problème je pense juste
qu'il y avait un truc y aura dix mille
de vie diminue de machin du minho 10
parties de trucs de chaque c'est tout
rampon depuis un certain temps que tu
auras 30 ronde il voit un peu d'eau tram
il va vraiment prendre est sûre ça fait
super marée de nouveaux arrivants là du
coup il a gagné un robot de nul effet ça
non ça se limite de ce truc
meetic amassé graves séquelles exemple
non mais française il faut juste un
arbitre ruquier le droit d'arrêter la
partie si l'envi vêtements parce que tu
peux avoir un tu peux prendre un grand
maître étudie enfin j'ai pas même rennes
gigabyte d'arrêter la partie quoi ouais
moi je trouvais point de penalty mais
bon après c'est dans les règles fager au
foot si tu as envie de ne pas attaquer
de faire des passes dans la surface ça
le droit fin oui bon d'accord on peut de
faire un pressing et essaie de te
prendre le ballon en fait je te le
pressing sur paris ce n'est pas que ça
arrive ça qui est devancé toupin il est
devant utilisent des règles la sas et
d'orties quoi proposition menu le plus
souvent non mais c'est harry mais bon
hier c'était la même manière ce cas rose
non plus par ailleurs pour vous il
comptait des gagnants donc bon c'est
juste dommage pour moi quoi pour
respecter ça
mabillon d'aider chaque c'est tout près
chacun est libre ainsi on trouve ça beau
trouver ça beau mais après c'est dans
les règles il fait ce qu'il veut en fait
ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas dans
l'esprit c'est toujours la même histoire
entre l'esprit le fond est le même et a
le droit
est ce qu'on ferait pas pareil à sa
place on sait pas on sait pas mais tu
fais un match c'est très tendu tu arrive
après trois heures de jeu tu as
l'occasion de faire ça pour sceller la
victoire est ce qu on fait différemment
je suis je suis pas sûr en fait je suis
pas sûr non mais je trouverais ça
c'était déjà que l'an dernier et tu doit
nous empêcher que ces photos dans la
galerie plus tard il peut faire et quoi
qu'il en soit ça reste la meilleure job
cette année a mérité sa victoire mais ça
mais c'est la fameuse expression
américaine don't blame the player black
bean games le problème c'est pas ces
bleus mais quand même c'est pas anna
canada il fait ce qu'il faut pour gagner
bako déduire que c'est moche de côté ce
très pragmatique c'est du pragmatisme à
l'état pur
tascan tu as le but de thierry henry
contre l'irlande
tu sais que tu as fait remarquer enfin
il a fait la passe mais il sait qu'il ya
main il peut se dénoncent à l'arbitré
dégueulasse qu'il a fait était tout cela
dit on est qualifiés on est bien oui
mais faire passer le même sens bien à
bize enfin des ventes un réflexe de
merde oui mais tu veux tu peux te donner
la main oui mais tu peux toujours
dénoncé tu peux laisser l'adversaire
marquer non mais tu essaies de marquette
a perdu parce que c'était débuté leur
compte avec des ventes en baisse juste
tu peux faire du but tu peux d'ailleurs
ben tu vas tu peux me more arbitres à
prédire y avait pas de but
le but de maradona en coupe du monde
avec la main enfin oui mais pas ce que
je dis juste que c'est tu prends ta un
réflexe qui est mauvaise sur une
fraction de seconde période où dix
minutes ont cru que du 7c nul mais bon
t'as le droit de
d'annulations sur gossip tu vois comme
l'iran contre c'était le match marathon
devrait peut-être son apparence et
arrivera ça non plus jarnac a et c'est
la même chose qu enfin j'arrive il
utilise la règle à fond ouattara qui
chaque jour henri son petit stand en
place une fois dans sa vie quoi mais bon
est-ce que si là et s'ils pouvaient le
faire à chaque match marqué en suisse 10
ans de la main ils le feront pas moi je
pense quoi on ne sait pas j'aimerais
penser vu l'a vu le comportement des
joueurs de foot en général
laisse moi le droit de douter
parce que bon ça en cas de simulation de
machin n'est marqué tout le temps par
terre est-ce que c'est mieux que nalaga
qui fait ça franchement je sais pas un
les noms de tous le nombre de mecs qui
tombe dans la surface pour se faire
siffler penalty enfin mon nom mais en
fait je recevrai revoir les trucs aussi
au foot où l'espoir est qu'en groupe
la vidéo mais qui simule ben tu lui mets
suspension après coup toutes les vitres
pendant un match il voit pas le problème
mais là tu te roule par terre tu avais
rien bois tient en quatre matches de
suspension
non mais ok aventure on peut régler les
problèmes en passion est là à parler de
lui de chasse tu dois régler le problème
fut le rêve est enfin là bon moi je fais
toi je peux pas je vais pas faire les
règles du foot on parle d'un jeu enfin
moi j'aime bien je suis fan et tout mais
je suis pas je suis pas hyper compétent
mais pour les déchets que je vois très
bien ce qu'on pourrait faire
par contre les gens qui sont contre moi
dans le chat mais bon ne sais pas je
paye non mais en fait qu'il a le droit
d'avoir vécu mais
bah ouais mais bon pourquoi ils ont pas
l'air aussi bien personne n'attend pas
d'être exemplaire moi je le ferai et
enfin moi je serai pas comme lui mais
mais bon tu géré par la verte est un
personnage public au signalement
ouais mais c'est super simple et la
tuque afin de speech à son avenir c'est
marrant ça reste que le speech as un
truc sur internet ça non mais pour les
championnats du monde machin c'est une
petite routine de ta vie non mais bon si
c'est pas un haka en fait c'est juste
que la règle est pas réglé que c'est la
deuxième année qui suit pas ses
critiques qui avaient commencé à faire
ça alors ça même pas d'un cas qui a
commencé pour moi c'est juste la règle
en fait s'il n'a pas faim absurde en
béton de facturer le joueur tu fais
exprès de tomber dans la surface quand
tu es supporter une équipe qu'on donne
penalty tu es très heureux fait le
problème c'est qu'il manque une saison
en se disant non mais tu as c'est quand
même le problème est ce qu'ils ont pris
la barre prison pas pris la barre tu as
faim moi aussi ça me saoule quand je
regardais match mais truc c'est que ça
arrive partout tu peux pas aux roses ne
se définit je pense ouais c'est fini bon
écoute tamazgha me serrait victoire
méritée peu importe qu'ils aient flag et
qui ait fait son truc à la fin il a
juste joué la montre évidemment sur la
fin du match où nos petits des bas fonds
soit on s'en fout ta sol du fort joueur
gagne audiences mais bravo ouest gso
vraiment du charme dans sa peau ouais
non c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'il
a vendu chèrement sa peau et je pense
que ça a rien changé appris que ma cage
joue la montre et il aurait gagné dans
tous les cas ce qu'ils avaient trois
points d'écart et façon sourire rien pu
faire pour leur venir pour le pour
revenir après ouais sow qui a manqué sa
chance au début d une minute et un plus
un web à la finale ne peut tenir
peut-être de touba c'est dur il vaut
deux secondes c'est très dur en fait
rare et ça lui a trop besoin de plus il
doit gagner
fait connu et après voilà mais oui car
outre en pitié précis auquel il a mérité
c'est juste le meilleur joueur cette
année à m
non mais c'est sûr c'est sûr après
j'espère que ce règlement sera sera
changée pour l'année prochaine je pense
que juste un arbitre qui fixerait la nul
ce serait suffisant en fait ce serait
suffisant après après alors évidemment
je comprends que toujours leur problème
c'est que il y vend en effet ils ont
leurs trucs en histoire de temps ouais
donc même si tu prends mon truc de dire
10 parties d'aussi de 10 parti de sadi
partie de l'autre en fait tu peux pas
respecté un ton fils
je comprends bien le truc mais bon ouais
non mais c'est difficile car tu vois
enfin c'est difficile dans tout de créer
des règles convenable c'est difficile tu
as toujours tu as toujours dit non pas
d'un système la règle en soit voilà
comment on peut dire dix partis de
chaque et bastien ou le no7 où cos très
bien pressé dès que tu rentres et des
considérations financières
parce que tu as d'autres contraintes qui
on n'a rien à voir avec le sport en soi
serait plus marrant de faire des sets ça
c'est clair
mais pour des contraintes financières
donc ils n'ont plus rien à voir avec
l'intérêt du truc en soi mais elle a du
coup tu vas te mettre des bâtons dans
les roues et tu t'exposes à sa main
comme dans tous les sports
comme partout mais bon ça c'est déjà pas
mal et non mais espérons surtout que
jamais qui mais bon après moi je le
connais en leurs arguments face j'ai
déjà lu qu enfin quand on parle ils te
disent ils te disent basse et dans les
règles c'est comme ça ça leur fait ici
soit avait été devant au score ils
auraient pu faire pareil cas c'est ce
qu'ils vont te dire non mais d'accord
mais c'est juste dommage de permettre un
certain esprit de jeu mais bon après je
veux dire je comprends le truc aussi
quand tu mènes à 0 tu vois autre corner
fois je sais offrait pas ginola qui a
voulu jouer le beau jeu mais aujourd'hui
encore alors qu'il a joué dans l'esprit
du jeu et calot pour tout corner se met
dans le coin face et août au cinéma que
de faire ça en fait quand tu y penses
c'est pas une vie du foot non non ça lui
donne quoi mais
ouais mais babou qui me choque plus là
en fait je sais pas pourquoi jacques
pessis non mais le truc fait l'argument
de dire quand tu es devant au score ça
te donne ce bonus de pouvoir faire ça
c'est pas si bêtes du coup ça donne un
un avantage celui qui a pris le score
quelque part fondamentalement vraiment
très bon ok je préfère être cependant
limité de partie - il y aurait plus ça
parce qu'en fait les échecs c'est juste
une partie dans le sens il ya un truc
qui va pas faire le foot ok c'est un
match il faut le gagner c'est juste
comme ça
voilà aussi c'est un magazine rapporte
que tu vas partir des débuts raccroc
ouais mais en fait enrôler succès une
partie plus une perte 1 c'est rare que
ce soit un ensemble de partis oui mais
là c'est le cas on habite juste une
partie
c'est comme quand tu m'as nofoot 1-0 et
tu te mets à défendre et tout ça et tu
vas tu changes ton silvares pareil mais
non je pense juste qu'un arbitre il
pourrait arrêter le truc un moment
convenable genre il continue à jouer
avec ces fous trois pions puis quand il
fait g4 qui l'échangé qui a arraché un
fou prend h1 et que la nature est
champion contre champion lattes à leurs
amis s'ils arrivent il arrête tu vois
c'est nul tu priori mais genre il aurait
pas dû arrêter quand il y avait encore h
4g cinquième de tueur à l'étude ont
encore laissé quand même et dès que ces
échanges et que tu arrives à avion f de
roy f1 tard est le truc où tu arrêtes le
temps paraître le chrono à trouver des
solutions
oui mais pourquoi tu es divorcée tonton
switch n'avait pas fait ça tu peux
dépasser
l'un des sens la vue d'accords minimum
c'est un minimum mais c'est au rugby ils
font ça en fait ce sont les mecs ont
commencé à s'arrêter tout le temps c'est
à faire semblant qu'il était blessé
de temps en temps bah du coup l'arbitré
non il fallait du temps et y'a plus
personne qui le fait donc là peut-être
que l'arbitré a le droit d'arrêter le
temps que j'arrête mon chrono
gates peut la jouer 2006 tu veux le
chrono est arrêté après avoir faut bien
gérer quand d'autres collègues fin on le
voit en général un mec fait exprès ou
continuer ses gammes de gagner on va te
rétorqué oui je tombe au tournant la
position je sais que c'est censé nul
mais je dois d'essayer d'améliorer ouais
ouais c'est compliqué
bon c'est pas glop une belle saison
bravo naka mercato depuis fort à gagner
et puis voilà j'espère que vous avez la
saison 1 se retrouvera bientôt nouveaux
trucs sur chaise comme ce sera des
protoss league wayne approach astic
donc c'est quand le premier match c'est
le 10 janvier les jambes
ok bon d'abord fait et qu'est ce que
vlad on dirait away parce qu'en fait il
n y en a eu la cie puisqu'elle est fou
tu la fais tout ça on a déjà parlé
d'ailleurs eh ben vous l'a dit disent
que si c'est dans les règles au niveau
c'est sans pitié et que c'est normal
donc mais il dit font tous comme ça ils
sont tous comme ça ils sont sans pitié
mais rappelle toi année peau sur des
connexions quand il a gagné contre les
veines il a parrainé la partie fin hier
c'est pareil en fait j'ai retenu le mec
se déconnecte il avait été là et fait 4
et des connexions bas hockey la partie
d'après je peux juste avant donné ça
revient au même
il avait joué il s'en fout face est du
même acabit que ce qu'a fait d'un grave
le rapt est pas content quand même oui
je sais mais ils le font tous donc on
peut c'est si on commence à être le
faire est ce que tu vas pas faire pareil
après aussi un jeu c'est pas ça c'est un
truc dans la vie aussi quoi une fois
qu'elle vient tarnac et tout en gardant
que la plus attentive verra dans la vie
au cours entre d'arnaqué non mais j'ai
proposé chaque jour entre les poches jma
faire les poches de tout le monde la
réponse est un jeu aussi
je comprends et je comprend enfin je
comprends vraiment naka personnellement
je ne ferai pas comme lui mais je
comprends ce qu'il a voulu faire
c'est comme ça c'est le bon sur ce allez
viens me voir à tous
pyatov